correctly well I Christina pitz you did
it's close enough what the [__] listen
you're [__] Joey Diaz I can't
Christina chrisa yeah but you're perfect
as you were I love how you said your
mother sucks your [__] is that what you
said in the run I don't even
know you're inspired smells like a dead
[__] what what Lis [__]
it you don't smoke dope right no I do
but I I don't I can't smoke socially I
get very weird I get in my head I like
to smoke alone and then I go on a Vision
Quest and I think about life I write
jokes I'm an alone smoker I also drink
alone I heard that's not good do you
drink alone when I used to I used to
love to snoke Coke Alone look at a
window and jerk off and take a [__] and
look at it for 10 minutes realize what I
ate the last three days and break it
down you looked out the window did it
make you like paranoid yeah but it was
weird the the path was very different
you know with cocaine it's like anything
else it tricks you at first you have a
good time your dick works everybody's
happy yeah you do that [__] for a couple
years and it turns into something else
like everything else you know heroin
weed everything could get dark on you
too much
anything is not good for you even Subway
sandwich you know what I'm saying you
eat five six Subs a [__] week you'll
[__] you know God knows what'll come out
of your ass windshield wipe it smells
that's a road dump when you're on the
road do you do you eat a lot of
Subway no I used to when I used to drive
when I used to drive all over this great
country of ours I used to eat a lot of
Subway veggie and cheese really wrong on
white that's my all time and cheese with
the veggie patty or just the vegetables
no no no
[__] that piece of cheese and throw some
lettuce and tomato like a p listen I
like a [__] cheese sandwich ain't
nothing wrong with a couple pieces of
[__] American cheese on white with
some mayonnaise okay at 12:30 when you
come in with a glass of iced tea with
ice cubes come on now who the [__] you
think you're dealing with some [__]
novice that wants I like going with
Burger King no [__] go to your house
little salami and American cheese on
white I can't I don't know I
podast with some [__] iced tea with
your feet up scratching your nuts
sniffing your fingers eating that
sandwich at the same time at the same
time you be the sandwich and scratch
your [__] nuts that's the [__] that
Kings do you understand me [__] Kings
presidents whatever the [__] you call
them uh dictators cult leaders they sit
there and they eat and they scratch
their nuts that's power any [__] body
got to have some limo to drive you
somewhere let me see you [__] eat and
[__] scratch your nuts at the same
time that's this is unbelievable this
you I love you so much Joey I love you
too do you know that Tom sigar my
husband and I we have Joey isms around
the house just so you know you live in
our home all the time number one we call
we don't call kinoa quinoa we call it
quau qu Joey Diaz pronounces it in our
home quow am I saying right I know what
the [__] I don't even know it's quino I
think quinoa quino it's quau in our home
thanks to Joey Diaz do you like quau do
you ever I think I've eaten it one time
on a Plane by mistake like I was stoned
and they gave it to me I'm virgin cuz a
V Virgin American [__] like that they
give you qu and [__] like that yeah and
uh whatever the [__] it is so the best
one of the best times I had this year
was honest to God and there's a tape
that I didn't see for months on it where
Tommy goes on Joe's show and he tells
him about this plane ride we took in the
Burbank Airport and let me tell you
something man sometimes I get dark like
there's some days I can wake up and I
see something I don't like and I'm in my
head you don't [__] see it but I'm in
my head and I'm thinking of murdering
people and stabbing them and then I'm
standing next to you and I'll be
narrating what's going on in my head and
I'll see things and I was saying some
stuff to your husband I could see in his
face he was a little bit [__] scared
like he was like what the [__] did I get
myself into and I know the incident in
question cuz that's when my that's
another Joey ISM in our home is whenever
somebody gives you an edible you eat
like a fraction of it and he learned
that lesson on that flight on that
flight with you wasn't that the trip you
guys flew in and out together like on
the way back you were sitting on the
same plane too no we we had to work
together so we had four flights Oh I
thought that was when you guys met on a
different flight cuz you like you ran
into him once right a little while after
I ran into him and he was going to
Milwaukee and I was going to Grand
Rapids Michigan we were both catching
connecting flights and I bumped into him
I gave him an edible then the second
time we flew together and that Fu we
flew on Southwest we had to go to uhland
Oregon and on that flight we were
[__] godone like I must have gotten
three anxiety attacks just got closing
my eyes and listen to Michael shrank the
[__] first album that's what I was
going to ask you about the anxiety
attack because I have a running level of
anxiety being a comedian and not knowing
the future for employment you know it's
like an ongoing thing and uh I was
wondering that about you so if is your
inner stuff all day anxiety and weird
stuff and stabbing people does the pot
help you with that or does it distract
to you from your normal tonight was the
first time we've smoked in a long time
here yeah I just I didn't eat a lot of
Edibles this week like I didn't eat
Edibles and I just was I started smoking
again one hit here I put a pipe outside
the house now so see when I sit in front
of the [__] computer I just keep
loading that [__] going I can't
do that so when I get up now no more
smoking reefer in the morning like I
used to get up and get high no no no no
so I just go now till about 1 or two and
after I finish Jiu-Jitsu whatever my
mornings things are then I'll smoke two
hits on the balcony just to get the
party started in my head right and then
uh at that time I was going through
anxiety because I was on testosterone oh
and I was something was going on with me
where I would run out of oxygen and that
would take the anxiety out so I say I
went to put a seat belt on and I would
not breathe I would I would not breathe
and then that backup of air would give
me stress so I went to see a hyp uh
whatever the [__] you call them some
people that fix your head and she hyp
ized me and said that whenever I feel
that coming on tell myself I'm in my
skin and I'm in the The Serenity and
stuff like that now I don't have that I
do breathing exercise in the morning
that's great with a with a with like a
monitor and like I told you with the
heart rate monitor but I've been doing
them for a while without the monitor so
I you know I still get it first time
when I go to Jiu-Jitsu when I get when I
start hitting the bag when I got in the
epileptical there's a point where
something happens and I get this skunk
sweat that comes out of me it's the
first reaction to your body is working
out and I go into a panic mode I can
feel it I go into panic mode like my
body doesn't know what to do for a
couple minutes it's a transition and I
can smell the sweat and and it's an it
covers it's like humidity it covers
every part of my body I can feel it
everywhere and after I pass a certain
point boom it goes away but for those 30
seconds it's go home you're going to
have a heart attack but if you die you
can't do the podcast you'll never see
your daughter again it's all these
negative thoughts shoot him I had
machine gunning machine gunning to get
out of there don't do it it's the same
things that happened to me before I go
on stage sometimes it's like a reverse
thing where everything just comes out
and tells you you're a loser you know
you're not going to do it you're going
to bomb they going to hate you what is
that you know there's been like I was
telling D at the ice house that that day
at 5:00 I was taking a call in the Ice
House I caught myself thinking about
calling the ice house and going I'm done
and I knew that if I canceled I'd have
to quit comedy like I was in that deep
in my head ladies and gentlemen this
this is three [__] weeks ago three
[__] weeks ago I'm sitting on my
couch on a Friday thinking about why the
[__] did I take this weekend at the ice
house with Don morrera if I cancel this
I'm might to have to quit [__] comedy
because it's going to get out that I
canceled at 5:00 I pulled a Mitch
Hedberg in Baltimore remember he
canceled at 5:00 on a Friday and [__] he
canceled the whole [__] weekend like
a month before he died a lot of people
don't remember that scramming to fill
the spot 5:00 you got 3 hours till
[__]
8:00 this is where you get ladies and
gentlemen when you're a comic sometimes
you know I bet [__] what's his name
bacon doesn't get that you know he's
perfect well I actually wanted to talk
to you guys about just want you bring it
up uh like yesterday for some reason I
had because I'm I'm getting health
insurance and it's going to cost me
about 300 a month and I had like this
panic attack for like almost the entire
day cuz you had to spend [__] 300 a
month the jewi ism came out not just
that and trust me guys I I bet if if you
went all the podcast producers I
probably make more than most because a
lot of people do it for like 25 a show
something like that so I'm I'm doing
fine but it's it's not the money I could
make if I was in an office on TV so it's
not the money I'm making here isn't
enough but it's just when I I got that
$300 a month Bill and then like how how
do you guys especially when before you
were headlining and actually making
enough money like how like how did you
8,000 times not just quit oh like it's
just I it was the entire day yesterday
and I I got home from a podcast late and
I was like it's going to be okay I have
Steve Simone CD and other stuff but it's
like I don't know how when you're making
$15 a set how you how like you survive
that I'll tell you how look everyone
talks [__] about drugs and alcohol
sometimes they're a good thing really
drink absolutely there are sometimes you
know 2008 Tom and I got married and we
were living in a one-bedroom apartment
in Korea Town we were just bar feature
acts I mean we had no money but you know
what we did we had enough money to go to
Trader Joe's every night and buy good
food and drank good wine and we sat
around and we ate Pudo and cheese and
got fat and made pecan pies you know
every night but some that's some for a
span of your time that's just a [__] you
got to do because you know you're going
to get there yeah and and I'm and like
like I said I'm doing like it's not I'm
going to be homeless or anything but I I
just started dating this girl and she's
talking about how much money she's going
to make in a couple years CU she's going
to be a lawyer and she didn't even say
it to be mean to me but I was just
thinking like God a year ago I was
making such and such and now I'm making
this and I'm a thousand times happier
but like for all day yesterday was like
I'm going to send out job applications
I'll do the podcast in the morning again
and I I just and I I can't imagine
making $15 at The Comedy Store we we've
all heard a lot of your stories Joey but
it's just like how like how did you CU
when you were making money at like a car
dealership I'm surprised it took you
until when we right before we met to
start thinking about doing that how did
how do you feel on the second of the
month me tell the audience how you feel
on the second of the month when you're a
feature act oh my God and they don't
book features till a week or two before
yeah so it takes this courage yeah is it
a courage balls courage
lunacy uh almost it's risk-taking to the
point of of insanity like you're you're
just but thing the alternative is worse
the alternative is I go back to law
school I dropped out of law school after
two weeks to be a comic wow so the
alternative is I've been fired from 22
jobs I was fired from or quit 22 jobs in
four years before I became a comedian I
didn't have any other options I [__]
blew them all dude this is it what else
what's Joey Diaz going to do for a
living besides being a comedian or an
actor like seriously like our digital
footprint now you can't [__] go work
in an office people you know hearing you
say all this crazy [__] on podcasts and
your albums no way this is it it's
amazing how you feel on the second of
the month he's back to the second it's
tell me it's just the
scariest [__] thing because you just
paid rent you just made rent yeah you
probably
have three or four maybe $100 gigs that
you have to drive on the books your rent
is 350 you have to pay let's say 500 for
miscellaneous grocery in my case I had
child support a Coke habit MH you know
so I cut out the building I would live
on people's couches so I could SN Coke I
gave up my privacy to snore Coke but
back to that question how you feel in
the second you have to wake up it's just
amazing how you think of your bills and
you get scared yeah for about six
minutes yeah you get scared and you and
you tell yourself okay so I could borrow
I got my mom I got my Uncle Tony this
guy will lend me money it'll be okay but
then something any normal human being
would go you know what I'm going to go
look for a job that's the question when
you say that to yourself I'm going to go
look for a job what do you tell yourself
to make yourself believe that this month
is going to pan out what did what did
you choose to tell yourself what would
you tell yourself on the [__]
8th
when you know you just got to [__]
listen and then people this is what you
don't understand we have a budget as a
comedian we have a set budget you know
if you have a flat and you got to buy a
tire for $79
there goes your [__] budget you're
done it's like an American family today
an American family has two children okay
I don't know what the cost is of raising
two children but the average uh what's
the average American [__] household
income for for us for poor people maybe
60 70 two [__] parents that that have
high school educations what do they make
in this Eon prob not even that much like
maybe it's 50 between both of them
they're working at least 50 and overtime
and the man's got to be working overtime
he might have to drive a limo on
Saturday and then [__] paint the
house on Sunday and the wife has to take
care of the two kids and have a [__]
job you know on my block there's a
Mexican daycare which means that we
don't close yeah we don't close there
times I'm [__] coming home at one
from a
gig and I see a [__] mom in a car in
a Mexican Vin van breed up and I see the
dad with two girls walking out of a
[__] apartment building at 1: in the
morning what do you think I feel like
what do you think it feels like him to
have to drive home now you got to assume
the guy probably lives an hour away 40
30 minutes away it's 1:30 he going to
get home put the girls down got to do it
all over again tomorrow drop these
[__] kids off again dayare what's
[__] daycare cost all day you know
Fortune you can't but back to this thing
what do you tell yourself as a comic I
would think of my bills and for a minute
I would go well maybe I'll s Coke I
could always Rob this guy but then
somebody come listen to yourself Joey
it's G to be fine and I would that's
when I would believe in God yeah you
have to that's when I would believe in
God for some reason or another what God
I don't know the Jew God santoria Jesus
Buddha I believed in somebody and I
closed my eyes and I put it on to the
universe that this is going to happen
and one night you're sitting there and
it's the
22nd rent is due on the 1 it always
[__] is your same
$400 and it's a 22 you're sitting there
and you probably got 200 in a draw in a
sock
but you want to suck some [__] this
weekend you know you want to do some
blow you want to buy some weed you know
so you take a chance you take that 200
and go [__] it I'm rolling I'm rolling
I'm going to Vegas in my mind this is
going to V I'm going to go to Comedy
Store and have a good time and you know
what if you believe enough that Monday
the phone will ring it'll be the Improv
with a feature spot for $500 and okay
you only get to keep 100 after rent but
it's like mck Jager said you can't
always get what you want but you get
what you [__] need yeah and I did
that for damn 14 15 years cuz when I got
the longest yard all I did was that
money was pay back the money I had
borrowed from Christine 20,000 over the
years the attorneys I got a chunk of
money but I paid [__] out and there was
by the 17th week people were reaching
out already like the creditors were you
know he's getting a [__] check so
thank God as that movie was ending they
were already grabbing me you know what
did you do on the second it's right well
the funny you say that you have you
start to have faith you start to go dear
God I prayed a lot I would lay in bed
and pray and have anxiety and smoke pot
to calm myself the [__] down and then
also I'll tell you what man when your
back is against the wall you do [__] you
normally wouldn't do yeah you suddenly
get the courage to call people you never
did before I mean I was calling every
[__] in the midwest people
didn't know who the [__] I was I was
like my name is Christina pitsky I'm I'm
on uh Chelsea Lately or I've been on
road ruls whatever the [__] my credits
are give me give me work I don't know
you that's okay you're going to know me
you're going to know me get to know me
now cuz in a few years I'm going to be a
headliner get to know me and I just made
calls and I [__] hustled and it was
full of anxiety and it's hard it's not
you know this Oprah [__] where she
preaches like you just follow your
dreams like people forget there's a
there's a few years [__] Gap in a bridge
before the dream comes in and when you
go to the supermarket you can't tell
them listen I'm at that bridge Gap let
me catch in four years I don't give a
[__] about your dreams yeah and nobody
talks about that span that you're
talking about the second nobody talks
about laying in bed panicking that's
what it was last night I was like what
the [__] is going to happen but yeah
just cuz and it like it must be why so
many people go back to jail like if like
like Miss Pat and like other drug like
when you were making money as a not a
drug dealer like when you get out and
you have to work at like a a McDonald's
after a week and you get a $100 check
like how do
you like how do you expect them not to
do it when I got out of jail I still saw
blow I went listen when you get when you
get in the halfway house let's say you
you're leaving right let's say you're
getting ready to leave and they go where
you going I'm going to pinsky's house to
work okay give me your phone number so
you have to write down a number I [__]
them up I got to pay you I have
questions for you I got to [__] pay
you yeah so if they called me it would
be a page and I something they go where
are you I'm at [__] Li you and they
go okay okay where's Christine pinski at
666 suck my dick Street and they go okay
all right bye click and that's it I
could be at least cutting a pound the
Coke and they wouldn't know it that's
why the system is loose those are the
holes in the system they sto furlows and
[__] after some guy in Boston kill
somebody that year uh before Clinton I
think after Clinton there was a
president that that was his sting to
stop the fur I don't know what happened
so there's no more Furlow but to make a
long story short they didn't know where
I was I could be robbing a [__] bank
and going back to [__] and what year
is this that they did it that way this
is $89.90 I got I got sentenced in 88 in
fact I got sentenced August 15th 1988
your anniversary is coming up yeah so uh
I got sentenced and then and then those
when I got out I probably got out in
February of 89 of Sun so how much time
did you do total eight months damn and
where did you where did you do your time
color in Colorado at a place called
first I I went to Boulder County Jail
then they took me to
uh this jail up in the mountains in in
uh like a ski resort which was a [__]
party you went to like a white person in
jail no no no but this is when you're
waiting to go to uh you're still in the
county system oh I you're waiting to go
to the prison system the beds are
overcrowded so you have to go to bould
packs where they sent me to Summit
County Jail they you could give the
guards money at night they go top for
you bringing your back potato chips the
TV stay on till 3: you put your feet up
eat your little wise potato doctor so I
was there for about a month and then
they shipped me to Doc that's Department
of Corrections where you go through
diagnostic for two weeks after they get
everything everything they ship you to
your destination I ended up at a place
called Camp George West in Golden
Colorado was an old army
bags and now I've been watching Orange
is the New Black I don't know [__] about
pres I I watch lock up a lot um did you
have to side with your race did you have
to like go with I mean did you did you
identify wife or Latino what did you do
I squirm my way through it don't ask me
how the [__] I did it it wasn't the big
gang place at that time it was 1988 guys
it wasn't a big like Mexican gang place
they were Mexican guys and they called
themselves something but everybody did
business with each other you know the
[__] mayates the blacks hang out at
some place the [__] Browns hang out
at another Corner the pecker Woods as
they call white people the pecker boys
pecker Woods oh pecker Woods they call
white people in prison Jews there like
three of them and they sit under a
tree negotiating [__] neotia and then
you have white peka Woods white and then
you have you know Mexicans you have the
the whatever and then you have a couple
Aran guys but they they were very cool
you had a guy named [__] that was a
motorcycle guy that was in there for
murder and he was a big Aryan guy but he
got along with the black eyes you have
to you have to get along to you know
that's great now we're all in this
[__] thing together you know yeah and
do you think it I mean obviously it's
changed since then like I don't know if
you changed a lot changed a lot the
system is CH you know you could smoke in
any of those places you can't smoke no
more so as soon as you go to prison
you're smoking I think I don't know
about prison I'm not sure about prison
but I'm sure about the county jail
systems you cannot smoke in county jails
I know you cannot smoke in Boulder and
in Boulder they used to give you free
cigarettes they would give you the the
grouping or the top whatever the ones
that you roll youself for the hippies
wait so how how did you get drugs in
prison like did someone put up their
butt and sneak it in or how do they get
how do they get TR in all different ways
like the at the place where I was in the
chick would stick a balloon with Heroin
a crank in her mouth and when she would
make out with the guy he would swallow
it and then they'd all wait for three
days until he [__] it out and then they
take it out of this [__] and they shoot
it well did you hear about the guy who
just got caught at LAX no it was a gay
porn star he was here for like he was
stupid he was here for like 3 days with
no luggage so when he was flying back to
I think it was Australia or London it
was a Virgin Flight he was acting all
fidgety and he ended up having half a
pound of meth in his
assole in three different balloons
there's got to be a better way right
Joey there's a better way to smuggle
meth than putting it on your [__] FAL
Express I say it once I say it again
people do it every [__] day right FAL
Express UPS thank [__] me [__] no send
it to a fake ad you know the way you
send that [__] is to to Lee's house
under a different name right yeah you
know and you do it just right so I would
send it to Lee's house under Joe
Banana's name and Le would take it in
and then put on the cops are still going
to go to your house and watch oh okay
they know it's in there so they'll go to
your house and watch to see if you keep
it you take and then just put in the
garbage and watch the garbage for an
hour or two make sure no little kids go
over there and then when everybody
disappears go back and grab it and now
you know for sure sorry say this part
again so the cops watch you let's say if
they
know if they in the package this [__]
that comes to my house every [__] day
that belongs to somebody else who lived
there before you understand me so the
sender's sending it from somewhere else
right and the guy at Lee's house is Pete
Holmes I'm just using the name Pete
Holmes he's a porno guy right in the 70s
yeah Pete Holmes boom [__] lead's
house so I don't accept the package you
don't accept it you don't even know
nothing it just come you get home from
work and it's sit in front of your house
got you and you look at with the rest of
your luggage and you don't know you walk
in leave it on the table for a little
while just in case the cops are outside
Goa and then put it and put it on your
thing you know how when you put mail
back on your thing we up there for a few
hours if the cops don't come get it now
you know you got yourself three pounds
of [__] me or whatever the [__] there
ups and all that other shit's probably
scarier you know there got to be dogs at
these [__] places got to be dogs at
these [__] places I'm just you know
that's why I when I went home after the
first year of working with you you gave
me a couple Edibles and you see just
pack and I got too scared to put it
under in the X-ray on like with the
check bags so I had in my backpack but
now they're doing like second TSA checks
like they bring a little cart to the
front there's a [__] already popped by
the time there see I didn't pop anything
I popped that [__] on the listen
when I go through when I was in uh San
Jose uh what's his name gave me a Chu
Butch Butch gave me a 70 migam chapu and
I put it in my pocket and when I got up
the next morning I was cleaning out my
pants I put my short on it was in and I
just put it in my pocket at the [__]
airp point the security line I realized
I got a Cheo in my pocket I just put in
the T next up my shoes with the [__]
phone in the shoes and I wait for it to
go by and I took my Cheo and blasted it
when I ate breakfast now I also heard I
knew a girl that would put weed in her
cooch not in her cooch like in her
underwear right under your cooch that's
a good place to put it like there's like
a pocket sometimes in women's underwear
and that's like a really place that's a
great place to cuz who's going to really
search a little blood and you put it on
there so even if they do take your pants
off you know what I'm saying you put a
little [__] blood in that snatch and
that [__] is good to go ain't nobody
going to touch that little wounded bat
there you go now I also have another
question White Lightning did you ever
drink any prison Hooch no white
lightning or Pruno as they call it a
couple guys made it but
no I don't see you drinking I did heroin
in prison I did crank meth like two or
three times with this white dude Clark
from Philadelphia t a big [__]
tough not muscle he was big like he was
muscular at one time but when I met him
he was like 34 I had to be like 28 and
he dug me he was in Philly had freckles
and [__] he was Irish and his chick
would come in that's who would [__] the
me out so I would walk by his room and
see him and his crownies like waiting
for the me like you know this is the end
of the world but I was slick I used to
visitation is Saturdays and Sundays I
didn't want visitation S I wanted to get
my dicks suck so I took visitation on
Mondays and Tuesdays so I had this huge
room on to myself and I'd make my
girlfriend come in with a skirt with no
undies on so I could eat that [__]
monkey right there at the visitation
Table and there was and I would sit
under the window so there would be a
guard outside your door with a window so
I would make her sit on my face and look
out the window to make sure the guard
wasn't looking who the [__] you think
you're dealing with L Mondays and
Tuesdays she was allowed to bring food
so they would go through the food and
see what was in there and then they give
it to me and then there was a [__] kid
there was a badass [__] his name was to
R piles and I became friends with him I
love I loved them I was also in prison
with the cury sisters from the 80s they
won the Olympics and [__] the Cy Joiner
really she had a brother I was locked up
with him he was a big [__] too I
still remember his face I still remember
a lot of those guys I had a lot of good
had got a lot of good laughs in there I
was scared when I went in there not
physically scared but inside of you you
have to have doubts and you have to have
a little fear if if not you're not
[__] normal goes I wasn't scared
whatever I had a little bit of fear but
I didn't show it yeah you know I was
really good at not showing it so I I did
okay but I I gotta got I didn't I had a
lot better time than I thought I was
going to have is what I'm trying to say
I really did that's so interesting I cuz
I think that's my greatest fear is going
to prison I'm very afraid of that and
being alone and uh with your thoughts
and and also um do the prison guards
mess with you they're [__] right
like they're out to get you kind of
stuff it's a psychological Beatdown
prison is not you know only in the
movies where they put Lee in a [__]
thing with murders you know what I'm
saying right in real life you get
categorized they're not going to put
white collar crime with [__] Crips
and gang [__] bangers you know I was
a kidnapper I got a accused of
kidnapping and I got and I pleaded to
second degree burgly and accessory to a
felony what's that felony kidnapping my
attorney weaved through it and it got it
nonviolent nice kidnapping is as violent
as it [__] comes my attorney hired a
a public investigator to get it
nonviolent and we came up with facts
from different people so he went to
different people that I grew up with and
they asked him different stories so you
never get into a fight his temper BL BL
we had a fight guy out the Jersey has
people questions you know how those
[__] people are they don't want to
answer nothing they don't know nothing I
had to call them up eight times if the
guy comes to your house let him in
nobody will let the [__] guy in you
know so it it was just uh so that's only
in the movies so you're with people that
also nerds that you know they're in
there for getting drunk and running
somebody over by mistake you know which
can happen to anybody it could happen to
anybody I was in there with a kid that I
remember still his face and how scared
he was every day he was petrified and
his parents would come see him every
Saturday and Sunday and they were
petrified and at the end of the visit
the whole family would cry and the
sister would cry and and it was so sad
because this would never happen to them
this was like you know like they never
dreamed of this you can tell these were
nice white people they were The Waltons
you know this shouldn't happen and the
kid told you the kid goes I never drank
I went to a party whatever the [__]
those things are yeah and they made him
do the [__] beers and he got in the
car without nothing boom and he hit some
[__] guy in a bicycle in Colorado
Springs bam eight years any eight years
of your [__] life just like that you
dumb [__] for having a cocktail it can
Happ for with anything I know anything
tonight on the way home you you can't
see nothing I can't [__] see at night
these jerk offs come out with a [__]
bicycle the bicycle ones make me CRA the
bicycle make me [__] crazy you out of
your mind those are the biggest bald
people in the world to ride a bicycle in
this [__] neighbor listen when I see
three Asians in the neighborhood I ain't
riding no [__] bicycle behind
and I and I love you I'm not saying
nothing bad but you don't want to ride a
bike around [__] Asians I told Lee my
story the other day when the Asian drove
me off the [__] cliff and Boulder and
the teacher ripped this thing up you
can't even write that [__] and the
Chinese kids sitting there all [__]
confused so why is that your biggest
fear prison you're a nice person oh I
won't I won't go to prison I have a my
stepfather my mother remarried to a man
that was a criminal and um you know we
got a lot of money real quick and then
all the money disappeared by my senior
year in high school the IRS took it away
I just I think uh it scares me to think
cuz I'll get like pounded and stuff like
I'm I'm just afraid of getting beaten up
like you didn't see fights or anything
like those people aren't psychos that
beat the [__] out of each other for no
reason that kind of stuff scares me you
know what I to a couple fights you know
and I got beat up one time I didn't get
beat up but I got put in an
uncompromising position and we broke it
up and me and the guy were friends it
was just a misunderstanding he had a bad
temper I had a bad temper I stepped on a
chair and he pushed me you know you
follow me so as I went to die for him
there was a counter there and I slipped
and he had me against the counter he
could have hit me I had his shoulders
but it didn't so in my world he's still
going to beat the [__] out of me you me
I got this the same biker that I [__] in
his box and put in his drawer I finally
got him one day in the weightlifting
room I got this guy I got this [__]
guy you know this you hit him with a
weight or something no I grabbed him by
his hair that's why I if I was a man I
would never have long hair ever it's bad
the first thing I go for is an earring
yes after 30 I'm going go for a [__]
earring because I'm not a tough guy and
I got to shock you I got to get in and
out my mentality is to get in and out of
that I rip your [__] earring off or
your gold chain I grab your gold chain I
twist that [__] around till it
breaks so you're [__] breathing Fair
turning purple I don't give a [__] so I
took this guy I was in the way and this
guy used to always bust my balls used to
make little remarks to me whenever he
was around his little uh biker buddies
and one day we got into a conversation
about the hot album when I was in prison
there was three hot albums what's we're
going to laugh I want you to play uh
well let me finish this story I used to
and I'll do an impersonation for you
love this [__] uh this kid was a biker
kid one day we're having a conversation
Clark was a biker the kid that gave me
the speed was a big ass bike with brown
hair big [__] good-looking dude
and he was my entry into that thing
nobody [__] with me cuz I knew Clark
from Philly but he didn't like me there
was like two dudes that looked that be
kind of weird they always made Italian
remarks they made stupid remarks in me
but this guy one day we talking about Mr
Brownstone Mr Brownstone unless you're a
[__] [__] it's about [__] heroin
okay Mr Brownstone won't [__] leave
me alone it's about [__] heroin this
idiot and his buddy tried to be cute
like tried to pull like they try to be
like comedians you know when you do a
podcast with comedians they try to be
cute you so so you took it in the ass
and he was trying to be cute so I first
[__] in the
Box I took the [__] no that's not the
song I took the [__] and I [__] in the
box and I [__] put in his drawer and
after about a month he found it this was
like a 22 in [__] when I put in this box
it was it was a cheese box welfare
cheese they said that's what you eat in
prison they just slice and tell you it's
American cheese I took the cheese out
and I took a [__] and I had to fit it in
the box and I took a a flag that we put
in BLTs American flag and I put it in a
piece of [__] and I put the lid on it
and put in his drawer and this
[__] didn't find it for like
four weeks he finally found it and he
was like going somebody [__] my thing
and and I thought I that would satisfy
me with him but it didn't and I knew I
wanted to I wanted to [__] this
[__] did so I had like a month
left in there I knew I had gotten my uh
reconsideration so you were on your way
out you knew this is your last chance
yeah but I didn't if you know anything
about jodas this guy was not getting
away with this I knew something I was
either going to steal his radio
something his jacket something was going
to go down and I'm in the wait room and
the wait room was slac comination weight
room laundry room mhm so he was in there
doing La you could put your laundry in
for the weekly thing that don't cost you
nothing or if you prefer to do laundry
on your own they had two machines in
there you go in there so I'm lifting and
he's talking [__] to me and it's just me
and him and that ain't no cameras Oh and
I asked him what happened he goes you
know he's one of those guys you know
those dudes that smoke a cigarette and
they laugh when they smoke like they
like he like like that [__] song I
Can't Stand the boys are back in town I
hate that I [__] hate that song Mak
angry because if you're a guy and you
sit around with your buddies
like shoot yourself tonight don't even
let the podcast finish those [__]
morons you know which ones I'm talking
about the boys are back and they sit
look at each other like we're the boys
and meanwhile there's nobody sitting by
them they got no strippers they got no
drugs they got no jobs nothing but there
those guys in high school that were cool
and the one guy and he would always
smoke a cigarette and he'd
go those
jerk and he said something and I'm like
what' you say like well let me talk to
you and I went up to him as as peaceful
like my I tried to really work on my
body energy and my face I didn't want it
to get R because then even would know I
was going to [__] knock him out but I
didn't even do that I walked up too slow
like I ask him a question what' you say
no and I [__] grabbed both his hairs
he had long hair coming down and I had
done that before and I remember I love
that move and I grabbed this hair but I
got that's how you do it right away I
saw and I pulled him down and he was
wide open by the time he grabbed my
[__] wrist it was just uppercuts Bam
Bam and then but here's what I did even
better I got him and I punched him he
grabbed my wrist so I had nowhere to go
so I put his hand around his [__]
ears buring his head there was a
bulletin board you know Christian
meeting 8:00 in the library I banged
this
[__] you [__] and I
everything that I had gotten in like
every rage I had and when I finished I
could say his eyes were all [__] up
somebody came what's going on in here
and that was it he never even spoke to
me like out that and he went back and
reported to the commissioner but the
commissioner was Clark so commissioner
said yeah you goofed on him what the
[__] I'm not going to go after him
because he [__] it you got [__] up and
I'll handle it he wasn't going to handle
it I rocked this [__] world he never
seen somebody grab your [__] hair and
cup your ears and bang your [__] head
against the door that's juano type [__]
don't be cruel by Bobby Br that's good
mood oh I love that s that's funny Bobby
Brown I used to get into fights with
black girls they would always sing this
[__] in the let me tell you something in
sth grade I know that I said this on the
ber CA podcast that with Felicia and ber
cha that you don't know what people go
what's prison like I go you don't know
what black people like till you go to
prison people think people black people
yell in the movie theater don't go to
prison I bet cuz they don't shut the
[__] up all night long yo
toell but right here look that from the
beginning this is what my bully used to
sing to me okay so there would be four
there would be four black guys ety
Antoine Spencer AKA chicken they would
be graveyard this other badass [__]
right badass [__] right and to Pals
put it from the beginning I did and they
put it from the beginning all the way
and they'd be like playing cards yeah
[__] yeah and all this would come on
and the [__] it was like African man
they would just start [__] going nuts
and [__] four black guys 16 yams
watching and I would I'd be the only
white doing that yeah yeah I'd be
[__] loving off the energy they'd be
hugging me and [__] CU dance but there's
a part fast forward uh like 3 4 minutes
when he goes into when this goes when
this just goes rap part when the just R
right the rap part yeah yeah there you
go right here than
that they would lose their mind you
around there was never been love that I
never been
found I gave you my mind but a true love
you would never find oh
[__] but there's a God like out there
that won't say
no and I want you
Jackie what and the [__] Ys would
just be going crazy and I would sit
there and go to be with me Bobby b or
with a bad attitude I can't compete now
you know my name now you know my game
you want be with me you look to be the
same what what what oh
[__] oh [__] so good can I tell you when
I was in public school fighting with
black girls this album came out that
same year and I was in seventh grade and
she would sing every little step this
[__] Rosen Johnson who used to [__] me
up and what I learned from the Mexican
girls that hair move that you're talking
about that's what the cholas did I grew
up here in the San Fernando Valley Mone
and I would watch the cholas they they
pull some girls I saw them pull a
[__] braid clear off a girl's
scalp that's how you do it you [__]
wrap it and then you pull the bitch's
head down and then you punch her head
that's how you do it now I didn't do
that I just defended myself I tried to
fight this black [__] but she was big
dude she was way bigger than me and she
would punch me in the stomach and I
could just you know I could flailed I
just swung but they're brutal dude she's
brutal now to get back to Christina's
question go ahead when we got to talking
about being on the podcast Christina
asked me if I said the word [__] and
got away with it and we discussed it yes
so did you see how excited I got I said
[__] did they're in a black person in
America that's insulted right now that's
right because they know I'm not lying
when 88 when this album came out Bobby
Brown that whole that before that part
there's a part where it's not him
singing and they're just going nuts they
would I never saw that it was like you
know when you see the Zulus going up and
down like that that's what it was only
200 years later later or whatever the
[__] the I'm sure you already have like
five tweets though from Angry white
people [__] them [__] them right away
they want to say my dick all right if
black people don't get men mind your
[__] business if you like black
people so much go suck a black [__]
how's that [__] suckers put that in your
[__] stupid [__] activist
sensitivity [__] act you dumb [__] I
love black people and the reason why I
said that the answer's question it's not
what you say it's how you say it ladies
and gentlemen I didn't say nothing bad
about them they know they would jump up
graveyard had a big afro and he would
jump up and down with a big chest to
beat with me but he would look like he
would [__] like he was like the Zulu
guy it was tremendous TR was tremendous
experience yeah and I do I I talk about
getting into fights with this girl Rosen
on stage all the time and black people
love it the most they come up to me
after and they're like girl you crazy I
love like they love that [__] they love
that [__] they know it yeah it's funny
cuz like the end bomb people are so
sensitive the word but I yeah but you're
right it is context and I don't think
that you and I like there's no hate
behind your story when when I told you
why I got away with it what did I say
tell them because you have no you have
no Hate in Your Heart about it no I said
cuz I'm a [__] oh cuz that too I got no
hate in my heart and I'm a [__] [__]
myself so they know it you know it at
home if you're black you're watching me
going yeah you got problems you got
problems dog so what's up Lisi I can see
your eyes are starting to close I can
see over there I caught you dreaming
about a Coke cut sub from from Subway on
12 in I think when that Green Hornet
melted it got stronger yes it did that
was a beautiful Green Hornet the [__]
Green Hornet Goomy bear melted in my in
the 14° weather today oh [__] I ate one
when I went to meet my wife with coffee
and the other one melted I get in the
car it's liquid I'm like oh Le's going
to be pissed it's Wednesday night I went
home my wife put it in the freezer for
Uncle Joey that [__] tripled the
intensity nice [__] high too oh oh
have to drive [__] I was right down
the street but it's funny you said like
when you're talking about anyone could
like hit somebody when they're drunk I
got drunk for the first time last week
and luckily I walked to the bar but I
used to you got mad at me once when you
people thought I was driving drunk oh my
God I called you [__] yelling and
scream and I was I wasn't but um yeah
like I I I drove a couple times drunk
and driving High gets a little bit
nerve-wracking but it's that's terrible
driving it's a paranoia I don't like
driving High either that's why I'm on
the bicycle time you no you're not yes I
am I don't I'm going to the haha what
what do I need the ha is three blocks
away what the [__] am I need car for are
you in there tonight after this do a set
why not I'm going to go do a set go home
uh I got to go swimming tomorrow with a
baby that's adorable 10:00 then I'm
going to go to jiujitsu at 12:30 and
then I'm going to [__] smoke dope and
watch Marin hey and then the car picks
me up at 8 I'm shooting the [__] Reno
like a doctor okay [__] him okay that's
exciting your Maring episode so what's
that tell have you talked about that a
lot already I don't want to reiterate no
we haven't I mean you said you were on
it but that you don't obviously can't
tell the story yet no I don't want want
to tell the story line then they'd say
you're Joy you're a spoiler alert
[__] just make sure you watch it
tomorrow night at 7 [__] o'clock
Pacific whatever on IC I was very
fortunate you know he had me on the
podcast and uh the executive producer
heard it and said I want to write
something for you do your thing and they
book me he was very real and it was
great because it was a fellow comedian
that came through from A to Z and two
guys have done that for me besides
Joe Louis CK and my man [__] uh Mark
Marin so I'm very fortunate so what
comedy cental don't like me so what
[__] oh they don't like me either
don't like me so what anybody don't
[__] like me you know what all you
need is three four people you get
through in this [__] life the rest
suck you can I tell you you're right
about that cuz not everybody likes me
there uh there's there's certain
festivals won't have me for years
there's clubs will never have me the
point of the story is I was thinking
about you I think about you a lot
actually and why Tom and I both just
love you it's because you don't give a
[__] and in this era of comedians I feel
like the the corporatization of Comedy
has destroyed it completely and you're
of that generation like you you remind
me of the Sam Kennison era of that
[__] golden age where people just
said [__] and and there wasn't there was
no holding back like I feel like you're
it's so good what you do and it's so
awesome I'm a student of how I grew up I
grew up watching s and son in the
seventh grade me too that's the best I
grew up watching Chico and the Man if
you watch the honeymoon is you'll go
Joey Diaz is stealing everything from
[__] all right Jackie gleon but I
love Norton I think Norton is the comedy
genius in that Jackie gleon is the
padding Norton has [__] specific
[__] timing I watched the episode two
days ago I'm still laughing I've
probably seen the episode 110 times he
gets a letter that if his his tongue's
turning blue he's got this disease disas
M so he tells Norton and Norton goes why
don't you sell your [__] story to a
magazine so they go to the magazine he
sells the story he gets home he tells
his wife his wife goes no that was the
dog the dog is g to die but he wanted to
leave money for Alice so that's why he
sold the story $50,000 so when he died
Alice would have money what a beautiful
[__] thing this is tele this is two
white writers in the room two Jews that
didn't get enough son that's how he
described them in his book they would
two Jews that didn't get enough summon
him and this is what they wrote every
[__] day Jackie Le and that's why I
admire him listen man he's my one of my
guys John Candy is my main [__]
but he comes in because of his work
ethic so he writes his thing he goes
home and they tell him if you're lying
if you don't die we're going to [__]
kill you we're going to take you to jail
and all this we're going to take you to
prison and lock you in there for 20
years so when he finds out he's not
dying he goes to Norton and he goes
Norton I got to go in there tomorrow and
give him the money back and tell him I
got a problem and he goes what do you
what am I going do he goes why don't you
on there and tell him that a doctor that
called you and you don't have
monochromia and you're going to live and
give him the check back and he goes all
right he goes who am I going to find to
play the
doctor and no he goes no would you play
the doctor no's like don't touch me I'm
sterile so that's where it starts it
goes to commercial next time you come
back you see both of them in the office
and Norton's got a goggle line what's
that [__] A monacle he's got a mon L
with a do a thing and the guy comes over
and R how you doing this doctor whatever
from whatever and he goes uh here's the
check and the thing I found out I'm not
dying he's going to kill me thank you
for the opportunity he goes wait he goes
just let's it he goes why don't we do a
story on the doctor and then he's like
no no he's very shy Norton goes a few
pictures wouldn't hurt what the [__] you
know that's how believe timing his
timing Christina he goes Dr Norton what
college did you go to no he goes what
school did you attend and Norton looks
at Ralph he goes PS 86 Oyster Bay and he
goes no what medical school right what
[__] medical school and Ralph goes
Oxford he goes in England and Norton
goes oh is that where it is I mean
that's little [__] nudges that so it
that's what I grew up watching Christine
so that's my mindset I also grew up that
you're a man I grew up watching Men I
grew up watching the Jerry Lewis roast
whatever the d Martin roast where you
were allowed to drink while you were
roasting people and getting [__] up
[__] up up Dean Martin would get
[__] up okay these were men and they
acted like men and it was a different
thing you know it was just a different
Brotherhood it was a it was one for all
these guys did everything together I
feel now we we're against each other I
feel even if when you see these
comedians you know they don't [__]
like you you think I'm a [__] idiot I
know when somebody likes me I know when
somebody don't like me I know when you
eyeballing me I know when you giveing me
the [__] evil eye you know I ain't
that [__] [__] you know well cuz
it's all business I think everybody so
invol involved in the business that
they've forgotten what the fun of it is
just to go to the club let your dick
hang out try new jokes [__] with each
other in the back of the room that's
what it is to be a comic and you know
what really kills me what you're saying
about this old school drinking smoking I
grew up watching Johnny Carson who's the
[__] god of The Tonight Show not this
[__] uh dog [__] uh who's not even a
[__] comic are you kidding me this
guy he does a good job I know but I
can't watch he's doing a good job
2014 it's not the [__] we grew up on
[__] when [__] Rivers was hosting
one day and [__] vanity was there the
chick vanity and she was dating Prince
she was dating Prince and Joan was
ripping into it on National Television
you do like you know you DT Prince you
know he makes Michael Jackson look like
a Green Beret going all you know and
Freddy Prince was going to take off for
Johnny Carson a Puerto Rican if Freddy
Prince wouldn't have shot himself he
would have taken off of Johnny Caron
history would have been completely
[__] different nobody remembers that
[__] then Jay Leno came in I remember
when J the host and when he hosted but
that that listen that's what it became
when it was when it was uh
listen you could meet people like you
meet people but they're not your friends
right I mean I'm met L Cool J I worked
with L Cool J for two [__] days we
laughed from Bell to Bell both days I
think go up to and take his number he
didn't take mine I shook his hand and I
went my way and he went his [__] way
when you watch The Tonight Show with
what's his name Carson Carson it was
like he had a relationship every that
came on now sometimes you what L you're
like who's this [__] 18y old girl
Carson would never put that [__] on
well how long car for a while right
didn't he do it for like decades Carson
would have never put that woman on and
and I watch a there's a great
documentary about Johnny Carson on
Netflix I highly advise that this
[__] was on TV from the
beginning of Television like literally
they invented TV in his small town and I
forget where he's from in the middle
Nebraska NE up I I think so yeah and
he's like I'm gonna go on this thing
called television and then he comes to
LA and he gets on The Tonight Show they
give him his show so he's in way back in
the day this [__] started and uh
yeah I know what you're saying there was
a genuin I think to people Iowa um
because there wasn't a lot to gain from
other people like there is now maybe I
don't know maybe there's it just seemed
like it was a more genuine thing a more
a genuine time or something when I got
off the blow the the the mission
statement of my recovery in the back of
my head I'm not talking to you people
like an AA guy I'm talking to you people
how I looked at my recovery was the most
important thing with my recovery was
getting my manhood back that cocaine I
had a dick and I had the [__] and I was
still smack in the face but I didn't
have my manhood I didn't have the balls
to tell somebody no I didn't have the
balls to tell this white powder no so my
mission when I got recovered like the
first 30 days of my mission was to get
my manhood back and I knew it would take
me a year and when I mean my manhood was
what the addiction took away the [__] I
ate in Hollywood because I was scared
that they wouldn't book me again or I
was scared that I would go to jail and
not be able to do my little precious
cocaine when I took that away way my
manhood came back who I was when I was
12 and 13 when I was [__] nuts do you
understand me when Bruce Lee died the
anger I had in my [__] heart was
tremendous do you understand me and then
my mother died you know so this built up
but I went back to Coco I went back to
just Coco you know the regular Coco
that's what I wanted to go back to and
this is why I know good things have
happened to me since 2007 I got married
I had a child but most importantly I got
my balls back you know I don't give a
[__] about work anymore I don't give a
[__] about your TV PR I don't give a
[__] about anything number one you
better talk to me like a man and respect
me like a man and I'll respect you the
same and I'm going to [__] own up to
it and that what that's the number one
problem that you're trying to describe
you don't know what to put your men on
we're dealing with a bunch of [__]
[__] we're dealing with guys [__]
[__] and you people at home should be
ashamed of yourself cuz you buy into
this you buy into these fake people
they're [__] fake 80% of people are
fake when you hear him talking it's
something somebody else heard and
they're just saying it to be cooler than
the next guy so you go oh my God he
really likes puppies this guy which give
his [__] girlfriend CL up the [__]
ass but you're at home thinking oh my
God he's so sweet you [__] jerk off
half these [__] people that you see
and that's what we're missing we're
missing that manhood we're missing that
manhood I could [__] on this hand I
could tell you yeah there's a thousand
Comics yeah I'm my God he so there's
five [__] men out there doing comedy
men men men men the rest of them are
[__] children [__] around but
there's men and that's what you people
that's what you're missing that's what I
miss that's why you see me with three
people two people all the time because I
miss men I miss men you know we're
comedians but before we're [__]
comedians we're [__]
men and you know when when you are a
female comic you have to for a female to
succeed in comedy when she feels her
ovaries kicking in she's got to grab her
balls I do all the time a lot of women
don't hung going Joey Jesus Christ look
at all the female comedy careers yeah
it's when they become a woman that it's
all over yeah it's all over once they
become a woman I my wife just became a
woman there's girls that do comedy but
once they become a woman it's hard to
convince a woman to do [__] comy what
do you mean by that wait wait do you
mean that they become mothers or they
become feminine their life changes they
see a life experience they see the same
thing I saw at 44 yeah all you dummies
are [__] kids I'm a man I've been a
man for 10 years but I didn't even know
I didn't wake up into this and you know
every woman takes a break except Joan
Rivers but they all take some type of
break or you know something to and that
break is and I'm not saying all of them
but I'm saying a majority of them just
disappear yeah and and the reason why
they don't disappear is because you
become a woman and it's very hard it's
like me I have a child I do a podcast
twice a week at 600 one day at 6:00 when
I fly it I fly it early you could only
do so much when you're a kid you say yes
to everything right or wrong Lee come
over let's know heroin and light your
ass all on fire yeah one day you're like
whoa I'm not [__] driving over there
yeah it's over once you see it for what
it is once you see behind a curtain
that's what it is to become a man to
become a woman you can't put one over on
me no more you understand it's over
Society it's over life you're done
that's that's it I ain't taking [__] no
more that's why the made that all
there's a part in your life and you go
that's it done I seen it for what it is
now yeah me too and then you see it
again when you're 50 then you see it
again when you're 56 then you see it
again when you're 61 the longevity of it
you see the field more that's all it is
we're seeing the playing field more yeah
I who a good quarterback a good
quarterback is somebody who sees the
[__] field yeah right you see a bad
quarterback you only sees 30% 40% you
got to know what everybody's [__]
doing and that's once you see that I
think that's what happened to me you
know I did something I went off on
something one night that I'm still
people still get mad at me a lot of
Industry people don't talk to me about
but that was the first movement to me to
become a man I stuck up for myself you
don't know how many how many times have
people talk to you weird in this town
like every day I had a meeting with a an
executive last week where the guy was on
his phone the entire time when I was
talking pulled out dick piics in the
meeting I'm like are you [__] kidding
me
like yeah no if they do that six years
from now yeah you might just reach over
and smack that [__] and Eyeball
him till he take and tell him put the
phone and work him work and put the
phone down before I shove it up your
[__] ass you took me out to this
[__] meeting to waste my [__] time
out and the other two and the other two
Gentiles at the table they'll be frozen
you know why because nobody ever did
that in this town and when people do
that right away you think your career is
over your career is never over ask Cat
Williams Jo an HBO special in spy Le so
you could call the whole [__] the
whole audience a bunch of [__] you know
you don't see the rest of the comics
doing that [__] ain't nobody else doing
what he's [__] doing yeah and he gets
arrested every other week so what does
that tell you what does that tell you
people buy the image can I tell you one
thing you said to me at a barbecue at
Bert's house a while back you were like
uh just say no see what that feels like
just say no and I did I've took your
advice advice and I decided to make an
increase in how much I make doing
standup and what I will do and I won't
do and I and I just remember you and I
just said no I said no three times and
then I got what I wanted and I thought
wow wow the power of no I had no idea
that it was as simple as going yeah no I
don't give a [__] I don't give a [__] I
will go work at Starbucks before I'm
going to do that yeah no no no tell your
mother to go you that's what you got to
tell these people and I know that's what
that's that's my new line I know
oh my God I have this thing for you oh
my god listen they're doing this thing
on Sunday the 18th up in a park in San
Francisco bunch of marijuana we want you
and Lee to come up and do a podcast
going to 80,000 people we're not going
to pay and we're not going to pay and
I'm like no no they were going to pay
like 300 no plane ticket no hotel for us
and all the weed you could smoke well
listen we take one H we're good to go
Cheo choose and I'm like no and they
couldn't believe it they couldn't well
what do you mean though no we really
don't understand what's going on we've
called dut people no no we seen for what
it is we're not going up there and doing
your Festival your Festival is doing us
and you're paying us those 80,000 people
are going to pay each and quarter to
[__] see us cuz we deserve it we get
up early we do podcast we tweet we we
communicate this what the [__] we do
this is hard work on our [__] end you
know I'm not doing [__] you know I got a
call this morning from The Improv he was
calling for something else that was what
he called for for something else let me
tell you how it works people okay The
Improv is a phenomenal chain they're are
backbone they are whatever but they have
little kinks in their game they're also
corporate like anything else everything
everything else is Corporate you got to
do certain things but they can't explain
what they do they can't explain why they
pay Christine a certain amount and why
they pay somebody who's at a certain
management company a certain amount
which is double in what Christine's
gotting right because it's their client
so these are all the things that you
people don't know about behind the
scenes I'm giving them to you right now
and if you're a woman by the way they
will try to [__] you a thousand times
and I know what my husband gets and then
I go no no [__] I know what
he's getting to do that and we have the
same podcast go [__] yourself of course
sorry go ahead very [__] weird so you
people are hearing this [__] for a
second so what they'll do is they'll pay
you some money for a while God
forbid there's a
holiday or just what they try to do they
look for you to [__] up so they could
offer you less and justify why you did
less well that Wednesday you did at the
earth oh we don't no you only had 180
people listen when you do do it for this
price sell tickets in the and you're
like No And they can't they can't
somebody else go okay you know there's a
thousand the reason why we don't have no
balls we don't have any power on our end
is because there's 1,800 suck asses that
do who will do it for nothing and eat
the guy's [__] out and clean the
bathroom and whatever I work from
strength I put 20 years of my life into
this the same way a plumber an
electrician puts 20 years I want I'm
getting to me you know what I'm saying
that that's it the game is over so this
[__] calls me for something and
the meanwhile he goes hey I spoke to you
agent and we want to give you Irvine
Sunday August
3rd listen at 7 o'clock on a Sunday at
irine Lu yeah good Lu and they know this
going to happen he's like you know he
said to me it's brand new people want to
come see it not on Sunday not on Sunday
though well I understand understand
first I got a family I gotta leave my
house at dinner time mm- to go do your
[__] the Lord's Dayo on the Lord's
day is that like why like UFC fighters
turn down fights cuz the only thing good
there was nothing good going to come
from you doing Irvine on Sunday so like
when they when they gave johon Jones
like a cha I think he turned down right
yeah and like like there's nothing good
come out what move am I going to make
here this is a business is and people at
home got mad well [__] He's a [__]
he won't fight CH really who's ch's got
a twoyear suspension Jon Jones about to
fight Dam [__] Cormier this is a
business business you guys thought this
was too Fu going jumping up and down no
this is a guy that's got people around
him that before he makes a decision when
you call my house now for a gig if you
call me and I'm on the road I'll tell
you call me back Monday I need to know
by Tom Monday then we can't do it okay
I'll call you back Monday you couldn't
do it yeah and when he calls me in my
house I'm the [__] thing I have a
list that I
ask so they can't Swindle me no more
they can't catch me off hard whatever I
have a certain list that I look at and
it's a countdown and if they follow the
whole list everything's good then I book
the [__] gate right it happens with
regular jobs too one of the last TV jobs
I got called for was a night job and
they say that you're going to work 6
days but you never work six days you
never and never it never happens you can
leave early and oh it's only 1,200 and I
know you should be getting 15 but we
only have 12 and it feels so it felt so
good to turn it down but
that's why like there should I like
that's why I'm a little bit Pro Union I
don't really know it but I kind of wish
there was a union that I could join
because it kills like I'm sure I'm sure
plumbers listening get really pissed off
when a new plumber comes in and does the
job for 50 when if they did for 200 with
the good guy it'd be done and the 50 gu
is going to break it and ruin it and now
everyone hates plumbers it just it like
that sort of lowballing really pisses me
off well here's the deal for a union to
be I had a great experience with a union
growing up because do you ever work
Union or you out I'm in I mean I'm in
Afra does that even count no these
[__] muds this is they don't do [__]
for you but you just give them money
it's a racket yeah I joined the union My
First Union was the warehouse workers
unit you pay like 800 to get in they
give you a book they give you benefits
dental vision I'm lying to you I was the
electrician's unit on to the
electricians union in Jersey through a
back door like a stock clerk type I was
like a 25 [__] units all right they
always give you benefits blah blah blah
for a while then but before that I got
into the warehouse one and that was the
best one I ever work for because they
got fired and I got fired for wrongful
termination so I went to pick up my
check I hadn't seen the shop steart I
saw the shop student he's like where you
been go they fired me you didn't know
that he goes nobody [__] told me how
long you been fired I go 3 weeks he goes
they're supposed to notify me in 36
hours let's see what the [__] why'd
you get fired I I got sick and I went
home to change my shirt I couldn't find
the supervisor and when I tried to get
back in they wouldn't answer the phone
cuz the the switchboard was closed he
goes I can't follow you for that he goes
come on let's follow he made we filed
the report here I was out of work like
four weeks filed the report oh Jesus a
week later he calls me come on down
let's go to a [__] thing a hearing I
won I end up getting all my back pay $16
hour was a senior in high school work
for 10 days after that and they went on
I got laid off because in the winter you
get laid off when you L trucks so you
collect unemployment so I was doing I
collect unemployment all the way on May
and my senior year in high school
because of MB Cent when they called me
back and they offered me the job back I
told him to shut up their ass no I'm
slinging pills and Coke robing the house
is what I need your [__] 800 a week
for I'm making that an hour and that's
the thing is that if you say no to the
[__] that you don't like eventually the
stuff you do like does come but if you
don't say no to the stuff you won't do
the stuff you will do doesn't have room
to come in yeah you know did you start
in La comedy I did I grew up here so I
did yeah cuz the only thing like with me
my first job at had a shitty boss and no
matter like I couldn't I'm glad I left
because whenever you I feel like
whenever you go somewhere they always
view you as like the first time they saw
you so like I couldn't move up in that
in that company cuz I started as a PA
yeah like did you run into that in La
like they saw you as an open micer so
now they
um no here's the thing I did I did the
open mics here but I didn't I didn't
step foot into the clubs into the LA
Factory The Improv of the store until I
was at least seven years okay so they
might not have seen you I knew that if I
if they got a bad first impression it's
very hard to undo it so I would drive an
hour south I would go to this [__] box
called Martini Blues every Friday every
Saturday because I guy was a bit of a
you know creepo R he liked pretty girls
and he put me up and I you know I
actually owe that guy you know and um I
just did I did a lot of spots out of
town okay I did trible runs I did all
the shitty things and then when I was
ready I Ste foot in in the in the clubs
here yeah cuz you don't want to you
don't want to once you taint that first
impression it's so hard what made you
get on stage the first time the first
time um you know I did the ground Lings
first when I was 23 cuz I had a boss who
was like you're a horrible worker he go
you're the worst employee I've ever had
but you're really funny you should try a
improv and I go yeah all right so I did
the ground Lings and I remember [__]
being in the room and they like oh
you're in a donut shop you're making do
your space work and I was like [__] this
[__] you [__] paying $400 for some jag
off to tell me how to be funny like I I
I knew I had some [__] to say and then I
uh I did the the belly room for the
first time and I I loved it I just I
[__] all day though I had diarrhea from
the time I woke up you know when you
first started doing stand up and you're
like I just got to [__] I would [__] all
day I'd [__] until the moment I would
get on stage for the first four years I
just [__] all [__] day it's your
anxiety and your nerves yeah and then I
saw this interview with Adam Sandler and
he said he had the same thing he's like
yeah I just I just one day I I just knew
that if I persisted it would stop and I
go well if that [__] guy can do it I
can keep doing it and then I just did
but I I really like the push pull of it
I like the danger of it it's everything
you're not supposed to do it goes
against your
self-preservation it's just and to for a
woman to do it it's very subversive if
you're saying something if you're really
you know cuz it's it's very male you're
you're taking a [__] [__] in your
hand and you're telling a room full of
people what's up you're grabbing your
nuts like Joey Diaz and you're smelling
your hand and that's a very masculine
thing and I I really love that CU I'm
very inside I'm wired a little bit like
a dude you know but at home with my
husband I'm a woman that's a different
story I like to cook for him I'm very
domestic but not not yeah our home life
is different but I just I love something
about the power of it and uh and jokes I
love [__] I love talking about
[__] and farting and everything
taboos that's why I love when you say
that you know you drop end bombs on your
podcast it makes me laugh I love that
stuff that's that's how my dad was
joking we're immigrants we're euror
we're Eastern Europeans that's all we do
is talk [__] about everybody this is
very normal in my house women are not my
my mother is a very ballsy woman she's
not the way American women are it's it's
amazing what you said those words
because a lot of women get offended when
I say that what I said earlier about
that there comes a time when a a girl is
doing standup that she becomes a
woman and then she sees the whole thing
and they a lot of women what are you
talking about you know women get
offended no matter what the [__] you say
but you know this feeling that you have
to sling a little dick yeah when you're
a woman to really survive in a male
oriented environment I see women in the
rooms and they have to leave everything
at the door there's an there's an acting
coach here in town ADV vanage chub oh
yeah she's very highend I hear that
she's very highend and the reason why
she's highend is she had uh uh chariss
the on and she had the black chick H
Berry H Berry back to back they won ask
us and both those [__]
thank because what she does is first
week in class she makes you get
naked to to go against your grain let me
tell you something you don't know what
life is do you have to get naked in
front of 24 [__] pretty people in an
acting class or do a scene naked in a b
IM
married I got to get in the bed with
Christine with my dick out and put rub
it on her leg and she's [__] married
and you got to act so they want you to
control this is why they take you over
the [__] top if you could talk to
somebody you're not married to when keep
your [__] heart on and act are you
[__] kidding me breaks you down huh
breaks you down and as a woman to do
standup let me tell you something it
breaks you down as a man to do standup
because I talk about sub now 22 years
later that I didn't talk about 5 years
in I would not even discuss it there is
no way I would tell those stories I tell
on stage yeah there was no way I would
have been a [__] star in my second
year in if I told a story about Lucy
stall Bush and [__] mbing the hooker
and lightting no Wi on fly I would not
repeat those things that was something
that happened a long long long long time
ago that was done by a person named Coco
right but you can talk about it now now
I can talk Family Guy yeah but it's not
that I'm a Family Guy it's that took
that that spine you build by getting on
stage you build it by getting on stage
I've been at Jiu-Jitsu for 16 months now
I was lost still two weeks ago because
now I know the steps it's like comedy
first eight months you're doing comedy
you're a jack off first year you're
doing comedy you're a jack you don't
know what's going on in your head you
think you're [__] you
know Fu you know Kim Kardashian in your
[__] head but in reality you suck and
then second year you start to get the B
third year you're on the road you they
throw you into some fire you know now
you're starting to get a little you
don't know dick six seven I came here
how long like I came here in my seventh
year and I was still green of course I
just got away with murder because of
my personality
no stage presence my stage presence was
very confident so it always deceived you
so you would watch me for three minutes
and go this guy ain't got no [__]
material this is horrible but my stage
presence as six years in was overlapping
still on my material it still is till
today it's my stage presence that makes
the thing go around they don't even know
what the [__] I'm saying they don't even
give a [__] but don't you find I find
that the best comedians it is about it
is about the audience wanting to spend
time with Joey it's not about the
cleverness at least I've never loved
guys that have clever [__] jokes I
know Mitch Hedberg you mentioned him I
get it I know why people loved him I get
it but to me it doesn't tickle makuch
you know it doesn't like grab me by the
nuts unless you're tell tell me the
truth [__] and when a man
doesn't talk about his dick on stage I
think he's full of [__] I don't [__]
trust a guy that doesn't talk about
jerking off or sex or any like you know
what I mean like you know those Comics
that just talk about like the cookies
and I got cookie and you're like what
the [__] are you talking about why don't
you talk about why you're so dark
there's a reason you're on stage there's
a reason something's wrong with you
right don't don't give me this like like
Seinfeld I know I everyone's supposed to
bow down but I just it didn't I didn't
get it I didn't get it I got Seinfeld
and I understood where he was coming
from was he the comic I looked at to
emulate when I got into comedy no but I
got him but I understand I got and I
liked them I liked I paid to see SFO
really took this [__] hot Korean
chicken but it makes me mad because I'm
like tell me the tell me how you really
feel I want to know your dirty secrets I
want to know who you are I wouldn't talk
about cocaine on stage I got to The
Comedy Store seven years in yeah was
where I got my legs to talk about
cocaine that's a good place to start
that yeah that's why I talked about
cocaine on stage the first time was at
The Comedy Store you don't have those
legs in the very beginning to to and
then you got on real world so what
happened was I did that in college 1999
or 90 sorry no where was College 98 I
went I barely got into school at the
University of San
Francisco yeah don't you know it yeah
and I [__] I got into school barely
by the skin of my teeth I didn't I
barely got 8 like an 800 on the SAT and
I get in I study
philosophy anyway I stayed a year abroad
in England and I came back and I was
desperate to get the [__] out of the
country again and I saw flyer for the
real world like come audition for this
show and I ended up getting I mean you
just keep coming back and back and they
interview and interview you and then uh
and they they're like we want you to do
Road Rules instead and I was like do I
get to travel great cuz I was living in
a closet in San Francisco with like five
other roommates I was so broke I had no
money and I just want to get the [__]
out and travel and I here's a secret to
getting on a reality show if anybody's
listening this is this is the [__]
ultimate
Secret in your final interview you have
to cry you [__] have to cry and I
knew it cuz they brought in the
psychologist lady and she was like tell
me tell me about your mother and you
don't like your mom you don't tell me
about your sister that did math and this
and that and I was like oh this [__]
wants me to cry and like [__] totally
did I just started crying I was like oh
I'm on the road R now and then I and
then I got it and it was great and I
took a semester off of college to do the
show we went to Australia for two months
and it was innocent it was an innocent
time for reality shows it's not like it
is now where these [__] [__] are
lighting themselves on fire and you know
for a [__] free bicycle like they
asked me to do a challenge when I was 28
or something I'm like what why would I I
can buy things now I don't need to
[__] uh light myself on I still do
that show I didn't realize it which one
I hate it it's the challenge it's with
all the people from Real World and I
used to watch it when I was in middle
school and high school because it's been
on for like 20 something years yeah
close to that and there's these people
who do like physical challenges like
there's a guy CT from Boston when I grew
up in Boston I thought he was the
coolest guy ever I find out like 10 like
now like 10 years later that he's still
doing these ridiculous events to win
like
$220,000 yeah it's just it doesn't have
the same Spirit of the show because
there's this woman Mary Ellis buam of
buam Murray who who is the creator of
the show and she came from a soap opera
background so she would cast people that
were really interesting and dynamic and
actually had lives and then they would
you know come together but then they
just started C when she passed away John
Murray just hired like a bunch of hot
retards like it was always like we're
just going to hook up in the hot tub and
get wasted and that's I think why the
shows got worse and worse like I don't
even watch the real world is it on
anymore I I I don't know that and I
loved it and I watched it for I love
reality shows like I still I [__]
watch the warst shows I love them yeah
but it really bums me out they're voting
people off and all that mean-spirited
[__] that's not uh that's not how it
started I only watch the real world a
year the kid had age Cuban kid 93 94
Pedro and then the chick was cute and
she started dating Puck yeah Puck I know
Puck I know Puck I met him out here at
The Comedy Store yeah but that chick was
bang and I had a crush on that little
innocent looking [__] from Arizona she
was like from Spain yeah I remember that
remember she hated Puck and then they
ended up [__] and everybody was
pissed off at Puck [__] her this
chick was innocent but I bet that that
chick was odd that's the only year I
watch I don't watch reality shows I
watch Doug Dynasty three or four
episodes I like when they [__] uh ate
dinner at the end instead of prayer yeah
it's like the Walton yeah I like The
Waltons I like the old guy the dad the
one that hates gay people you know as a
as anti- PC as that is like that's
that's who that guy is [__] change an
old dude what do you care if he h gays
you don't have to watch him who care
what do you care you know you're a fat
[__] we love we love those [__] shows
about food oh I love that you know that
dude Diners Dives that [__] you
can watch him for two hours sitting
there he just got fired right is that
Richmond no no no the guy they're
putting Richmond they're putting
Richmond's show on NBC oh what they're
putting it on they don't give a [__] he
didn't say nothing wrong do they're just
[__] people that senstive see that's
the going back to the the Carson era the
time when people could just [__] say
what they really felt about stuff there
was no Twitter though to crucify them
over it you know I mean I'm sure Johnny
Carson called people CT left and right
it's it's really amazing how sensitive
people are and I'm surprised any like
athlete is allowed to have Twitter like
it just there's always a scandal every
couple months and it just happened
yesterday with an Old Coach I'm
surprised any of them do it like it's
just so easy to piss someone off in 140
characters that's scary dude let me give
some shout outs real quick get this
[__] party started here you know what
I'm saying okay all right my man man
Nick
Poma Neo Savage Vick Berg Jesse Wright
my girl Joey rooklyn looking bad at a
[__] John Shaw John Keats and
Chris Cruz I love you
[__] said where's the music you
don't who are these people are these
your listeners these are people who
[__] uh send me [__] on Twitter or
Facebook
post these people shouts out they
support your show makes them feel
nice
okay why don't you put your [__] is this
Big Daddy Kane hey my husband just met
him no this is raw right oh [__] oh [__]
goalie goalie Wiggly goalie goie goalie
goalie so Wednesday night [__] what
the [__] you want what were you doing
what are you going to do watch TV sit
there and [__] the dog like a [__]
half a bag [__] it it's Wednesday night
you're up you're late who gives a [__]
about work tomorrow you're getting paid
Friday not thday [__]
inck Constantine rain you're [__] up
[__] you're lucky I love you over
there in Germany with those [__]
neo-nazis you're run
away so we got Christine whatever your
[__] last name is this uh this
Gable's kicking in
oh and I'm [__] hot you want to put
the air on for what the [__] put the air
on for 2 minutes who gives a [__] so
you're Ontario California this week
Ontario yeah Ontario California at the
Ontario Improv this week they actually
got my husband and I to do a week
together which is very rare so if you
want to see Tom sagora and myself do
jokes this whole weekend uh Friday
Saturday Sunday Thursday Show's not
there for some reason which is fine with
me now who goes up first you go up there
and everyone ask that you go up there
and throw some heat FR of your hband
[__] his world up I'll tell you what
make him St a little bit I think what
we're going to do I think we're going to
flip a coin I think that's the best way
to do it so nobody gets weird what do
you think it's five shows split it down
the middle and flip a coin for who gets
the the third show the headline okay so
just go to pick them and just go we'll
flip a coin
for for Sunday Sunday Sunday sucks yeah
Sunday that's the one that bothers me is
me too it's it is the Lord's day you
should be home there tast [__] on me if
I'm home I don't mind working on ter
just [__] got to drive 80 miles but
Sunday is the day that it just irritates
the [__] out of me because I don't want
to fly Monday morning it's the worst the
last thing you ever want to do in this
lifetime is fly Monday morning Monday
mornings are just confusion you know
Monday and Tuesday morning is still
[__] up didn't they blow up the world
trait on Tuesday probably I think so
Mondays and Tuesdays I don't like I had
a drug dealer friend he used to always
go that means don't do [__] on Tuesday
cuz you complicate yourself when I was a
kid in ' 83 he told me that quote so I
would never make a move on a Tuesday
okay I would always say I'm coming to
pick the coke up and I'll go I'll be
there tomorrow not on Tuesday you won't
I don't do deals on Tuesdays can I can
we ask you I've been dying to ask you
this stuff how much more time do we have
I don't know if we want to we don't give
a [__] okay do it what what
what what was your childhood like like
who the hell who is Joey Diaz where did
you come from how are you like
this uh
to be a really good comic to do anything
in your life you have to have a point of
you don't give a [__] yeah you don't
give a [__] this was not who I was when
I was 12 I was very anal my family was
like this my mother was a very I don't
give a [__] situation you know what I'm
saying like my mom would buy a first
class tick on a plane and she took a
bottle out and mix her own drinks and if
you look at it she go [__] my money's
as green as yours get the [__] around
turn around my [__] business and you
would I would sit there looking straight
ahead in this chair I mean she caused
problems everywhere but that was her
mentality she was a SPI yeah this is my
[__] money [__] you you know don't
look at me right the way they want to
judge everybody wants to [__] judge
you you know no what's her was she an
immigrant or yeah she was an immigrant
so okay that mentality was in in my
house growing up I just didn't
appreciate it I didn't like it I didn't
care for it yeah I did everything I I
could to run away from the guani moment
ality of men The Possession the jealousy
the uh the control I I'm still semic
controlling but that other [__] that
comes with it I don't I erase that I
still have the rage it's in my blood
that [__] Cuban that Spanish blood is
still in your in your heart you know so
what I did was when my mother
died I had to do a die situation how old
were you when she pass 15 16 so I had a
Do or Die situation okay it was a sink
or swim situation either my attitude was
going to change 5 years ago I told you
it was when I became a man no it wasn't
I was very it was when I became a scared
little boy yeah you know that's why I
got into drugs that's why I stole that's
why I sold drugs that's why I did 10
million bad things at that age for like
six or seven years until I finally got
arrested and I did a bunch of bad more
[__] after I came out I just paid my
sins and you know I cut a deal with and
that was it you know I couldn't deal
with myself but I met this family the
runnies and Mike runny is a guy I still
talk to I talked to him Saturday and he
was pissed off cuz he had a drive he had
to work Saturday night and he was a
manager at a [__] whatever but it was
weird his mentality was like I was
raised and he was one the only person in
his house that had that I don't give a
[__] mentality say one more word and
I'll put you through that [__] wall
[__] him tomorrow go down in theor and
be the best you can you know he had that
prais and that's what took over and I
lost that for a while Rogan always
discusses that when he first met me I
wasn't funny he goes you were the last
thing but funny really I think it was
then one day the [__] switch turned
time and it was the day that I knew I
wasn't going to
Montreal I knew I wasn't going to get
APA or CA or three Arts to go oh my God
he's brilliant brilliant brilliant
brilliant I knew all these things yeah
you know the laugh Factor didn't make me
a regular yeah there was just you know I
would I didn't get invited to a lot of
things so I knew what my demeanor was so
I said if you're not gonna like me I
might as well do this my [__]
way yep and that I did that for a while
like I even though I was coked up and I
was a little scared moments of balls
would come out like when I got the
longest yard when I sent the envelope in
for Spider-Man 2 when I told the guy on
the Hardy commercial to go [__] himself
because there was no break on the truck
and he thought it was me and he yelled
at me and I don't no [__] yell at me
[__] and the whole crew stopped
cuz he was like an international
director you don't say that [__] to me
that was 2009 and those were the things
that I was like that's it this Hollywood
[__] is ending now like after I went off
on Jeff Valdez at that Marilyn Martinez
that was it when I walked to my car I
remember looking at Dice and Johnny
Sanchez's face as I walked out the comy
store and they saw something and I'm
like dad's the guy used to be that's the
guy I want to come back I was raised
with a mentality that
my little daughter is
smacking for some reason she at that age
she Pets the cats and they become smacks
the other day she kept twisting my face
at the park and I had to yell at her and
today she hit my wife my wife didn't say
nothing and I attacked her that's a d
That's the Val's mentality my mentality
sto these [__] the way they
should have stopped Hitler and Munich
right if they would have stopped hit if
I say to you hey hey Christine your tits
are banging today if you don't say
listen you SPI fat [__] how
about I go [__] your dick up in the ass
how about I call your [__] wife you
fat [__] you don't say that if
you don't say that yeah you're done I'm
going to eat you alive cuz you got to
push backat you alive in this Society in
today's society if you're a woman this
is what I'm going to teach my wife my
daughter this is what my wife knows I
you know when I was a kid I dated this
girl and she was kind of a [__] [__]
but she had good [__] I ate her [__]
she sucked tremendous dick she let me
put Coke rocks in her ass and this was
way back in ' 84 people were just
starting to put Coke rocks in people's
[__] and she let me Pioneer that
fantasy I had just to see the coke Rock
melt in your [__] tremendously it's
like a [__] when you put a spoon in a
when you put a drug in a spoon and you
put that lighter on there it just
dissolves same way cuz the pussy's moist
once that cocaine hits
it is that good for her do she get high
I'm assuming that nothing do with me I
don't give a [__] about her I want some
on my tongue I want help people I ate
some coke with [__] rocks on it you
know what I'm saying what was my point
anybody know my point being a woman with
your daughter grabbing your nut so the
point being that uh I was with her at a
bar one night in 198 summer like July of
83 84 like 30 years ago we were at a bar
one night and I went to the bathroom do
a bump and when I came back there was a
dude that dripped from head to toe with
booze on them like saying you're crazy
and she's like next time I I tell you
the seat is taken go [__]
yourself you follow me that was a girl
from the neighborhood when I went to the
bathroom some guy thought he was cute
and tried to sit down next him she told
him no the guy didn't care she threw his
[__] drink in his face that's is
terrible that's old school [__] I moved
here with Carol dirty [__] horse
stripper I took it down to the Improv I
get up to go to bathro I come back
Jackie Flynn sitting next to her and
they talking Jackie get up that's the
first time at Jackie
went get up what you don't know don't
make get this [__] chair and hit you
with [__] time that was my first
meeting ever with like Jackie Flynn when
he was they all ran together white Steve
White they were all managed by that same
manager at The Improv
1997 I shouldn't had to say that to that
[__] guy do you follow what I'm
saying right a real woman that's a woman
that girl in Jersey I was 21 at the time
and she threw the glass at the [__]
dude that's a woman don't but now
Society oh my God is that the [__] the
[__] you talking about the other day it
happened at Marie Etc we were sitting
there some that creepy dude that's
always there Mak him believe he's a
writer yeah some chick came with a book
and she [__] she read she took it out
and the guy's like what book are you
reading that's Gentile [__] that's
Sherman Oaks type [__]
you what book are you reading that is
and she looked at him dog and she went
does it
matter you understand me that's abroad I
what you it shakes me and then the guy
kicks up and comes up I read one get the
[__] out of here you know what I learned
I I just did this uh show with Marlon WS
on it's called funniest wins on TVs and
I hung out with a lot of black people
filming it and I
learned who was telling me one of the
black Comics this dude was like white
girls are so different than black girls
because a black woman won't [__] talk
to you if she's not really interested in
you you know what I'm saying like a
white woman will talk to you even if
she's not interested in you sexually
black girl won't even be like get the
[__] out of my face and I'm like God I
kind of like that I think I should adopt
that I mean I'm I'm pretty much
dismissive in public of other people you
know just cuz I don't want dudes talking
to me but I really like that I really
respect that you know what I'm saying
guys have to act like that that's how we
act like as a man yeah I pull you aside
I don't have to be a [__] gorilla I
go Lee do me a favor you ever say that
to me again I'm going smack you in the
face and then I put my hand out and we
shake hands and we have an understanding
yeah and you want to be cute again I'm
going to smack you in the [__] mouth
now now you know I warned you that's how
I grew up I grew up with guys that go
can I talk to you for a second listen
before you made that comment the next
time that happens we're want to box as
men okay and you look at I couldn't
believe a man would say that to me it's
crazy and he puts his hand on you put
your hand now we know where we [__]
stand that's the school of mine I'm from
say that to say that to one of these
[__] [__] Gentiles in Hollywood
[__] at the par with Jay Davis say
went to one of these [__] [__]
[__] comics that you know uh hipsters
uh hipsters you know alternative and
that's how men talk yeah that's how men
talk I have my sight and a few Comics
that when I see them I'm going to pull
them aside and go can I talk to you for
a second there was a certain day I saw
you but there was people there and you
made that remark what did you mean by
that I've always been a gentleman to you
and insulted me did you are you trying
to be cute and from that reaction right
there I'm my hand stays right here
because if it's a [__] up reaction the
hand the salami comes right up and
smacks him and right there when you're
telling somebody that when they don't
expect to see it their body is they
don't even know what the [__] going on
cuz that's how I was raised I talked to
you when when you told me about that
when I got the call from redband that
you were drinking I called you like a
man I said you're my brother I don't
care how you live your life but you
can't do that here yeah and drink and
drive here it's
2013 how [__] are you you get a DUI
right do I smack you now or do I throw
you under the [__] jail and sick 10
black dicks up your ass I wish I had
like a like a [__] uh spitball yeah
that connected big black dead dicks that
they shot and he just shot them at
people and a dick would come at him and
just [__] hit him in the face we got
to [__] get an inventor out there on
Twitter like big black dicks to shoot
him at people I'm sorry where where was
your father my father died when I was
three [__] so you basically orphaned by
the age 15 and after that I had no
parental No Parental I ran my own [__]
you're kidding so nobody
I moved in with a friend's family I
stayed there for a year and a half then
I moved in for another friend's family
stayed there for a year and a half and
that was it once uh SE I've been a nomad
since September of 82 I have been solo
and I was 18 years old Jesus paying my
own bills no clothes apartment shoes I
got a little help and everything else I
robbed I I got jobs to fill in the
[__] gaps but you know this was a and
God threw me a [__] bone and threw
comedy in my life something you know
when you have nothing to lose you got to
try everything yes got nothing to lose
guys got to try everything who the [__]
are you you know so I got hustle you
hustled it sounds like you learn how to
hustle and care for yourself very quick
you do what you got to do right if
you're not hustling you you're to die
know and today's society you got to
hustle there's no jobs there's no job so
we going to sit at home and go there's
no job no you got to go out there and
put two them two together you got to
invent a combination you know you got to
buy those wipes from uh you got the
black dick uh paper no you got get the
Dollar Shave Club got get dollar sh
those are great have you used them what
tremendous they're like a nice you use
them on your vagina or on your [__]
on my [__] now here's my problem
maybe you guys can help me with it when
I take a [__] not all the time but a lot
of the times now I have to go straight
to the shower after the [__] cuz there's
so much cleanup it's a NeverEnding wipe
and sometimes I wipe and then later on
the day I'll go back and they's still
Brown there and I don't know like what's
wrong with my butthole that happens to
man you get your [__] gets itchy as
[__] it always happens to me right
before I go to bed OHP the shower today
I had today I had an itchy [__] like
a [__] I got to sneak into the
bathroom pull my pants down get toilet
paper stick toilet paper on my ass and
the big brown spots and a toilet paper
I'm 50 [__] years old that's why I
have the warm up Charlie is I keep it on
top of know when I I wipe my ass then I
dry with the [__] whatever and you
stick that finger deep in the you get
the barnicles you're beautiful you're
brand new but while it's like your [__]
don't stop like it leaks the heat makes
the and once it's hot out and that [__]
touches your [__] with that salty
sweat oh reminds me of roots when
they're [__] in the boat sweating and
dying and smelling you know cuz an
[__] with salt on it and [__]
sweat you know that sweaty salt plus the
[__] [__] the [__] burns like yeah so
that's that's why every time I'm sorry
about this people but let's discuss it
that's why every time you're like you're
you have to lick a girl's [__] you
have to let a girl lick your [__] I'm
like that it can never be ever clean
enough but I'm not going to tell a girl
lick my [__] I got a peanis I go
guess what they had in nobody's looking
your guys' ass wait wait but guess what
guess what was that Vegas this weekend
my room what a [__] bedet I love I
want a bed I want one I use it right
away let me tell you something I I want
to get a bedet company to [__]
sponsor podcast cuz I could sell those
if somebody installs them for $9.95 plus
a plumber oh yeah have no idea the
difference of a day would they're doing
it over in Japan where you take the [__]
and it washes your ass automatically
that's great before the [__] even hits
the water you know and that's what it is
a thousand little guns with water this
was a and I I had a Beday Jersey and my
mother's house in that house day and I
would take a [__] and turn the day on
but if you turn on too fast hit you in
the face go too fast now does your wife
uh is she aware of your bowel movements
and your like do you do you have an open
door policy see when you take a [__] or
is it closed door I don't want nobody in
the bathroom watching me [__] or
smelling that nightmare I can imagine I
don't want to smell nobody's [__] I
don't mind like walking by and going
Christine yeah you [__] that
[__] up you know I don't mind
giving somebody credit what creditors do
but I'm not going to go there and brush
my teeth and comb my hair and then yell
out and go it smells like [__] in there
when you went in there the [__] is wrong
with you you don't see me going in I'll
put before you if you're going to take a
[__] let me know that's the deal I do
that you going to take a [__] let me
know so I get everything out just in
case I got take a jump in the shower I
don't want to walk in there but there's
a lot of times she jumps in the shower
at 8:30 and from 8:40 to about 8:52
that's my Prime ass open up that's
coffee that's coffee that's the fruit
and that's the breakfast after that
piece of wheat bread my assle singing
Jack like a doctor and I go and that and
I [__] it up and I like when it just
falls out like it's like limbs like it's
like arms falling out of your assle and
you can hear him hitting the and I like
when they like you fill it up and then
it hits the metal and it just sits there
like 18 Vietnamese vets laying on top of
each other and the [__] all over like
going this way and Crossway then you
flush it and the [__] don't go down so
you got to get toilet paper and push it
down nope not my experience I I can't
even imagine the dumps you take oh my
God are they as are they bigger than
your head I can't I what you sometimes I
look at them and I like I'll count out
four feet of [__] really in 12 in
intervals I took a picture I took one
how big was the question mark
he tweet that one on Twitter I saw that
one I think I congratulated you that had
to be 30 in that monster wow and before
that it was like a 12 in and an 18 in
that I flushed wiped a little bit and
then sat back down and when that one
came and I was like damn what the [__]
have I been eating now do you fart in
front of your wife oh yeah she farts in
front of me too I fought real I don't
give a [__] I was farting up on the
plane back from uh Vegas last weekend
and some and the was empty but right
away these douchebags want to sit around
all right I'll give it to you I'll give
it to you plane farts are the best
because the sound of the engine
camouflages anything and it could be
anybody it could be you could be the
girl next to you f who knows the best
person I've ever killed with farts on a
plane as Joe Rogan I have destroyed him
to the point where I've W I've woken him
up like and he's looked at like half
asleep like d what the [__] is that
he'll put his shirt on he wrote a blog
about one time where I fought on a plane
and he goes He awoke to the smell while
while Antonio Banderas was teaching
black kids out of dance I [__] like
my ass off I woken him up from [__]
uh because we got to catch that 6:00
a.m.
flight I got two breakfasts in me
already by 8:30 my [__] is on fire my
bad I'm not big for taking a [__] let me
ask you this real quick I have to change
the subject so you go into a Town M you
go to San Francisco you get there
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday you come
back Sunday morning M now while you're
in San Francisco you [__] correct you
[__] once you [__] Twice But as soon as
like this is my thing I'll [__] like I
[__] in Vegas this we I was there a day
and a half I [__] two times three times
when I take a shower when I come home
unpack throw my clothes in the hamper
put the soap case away put out the sleep
at me machine while I'm putting the
sleep at me machine like my stomach is
already hurting I do the same thing
every time I come home that's why I
don't take auditions after a flight
nothing can't it's not going to work for
me you're just wrecked it's not going to
work for me I do the same thing I walk
in my room my wipe nose I go in my room
I take the clothes out put the suitcase
away I get naked I go on the computer
make sure there's no late stuff then I
get naked and I take a [__] that even
let's say I wake up that morning it's
like my [__] holds it back it's like
in these hotel rooms my [__] thinks
it's being watched so he just drops like
an 18 in here a 14 inch there a 10 here
I'll drop a couple threes but that's it
but when I get home my ass knows it's
home knows yeah so I will take a [__]
that is so 40 50 Ines and that's the one
that baffles me because I'm like my
intestines have been holding back it
feels like they've been cheating you
they cheat and it even comes out it even
comes out still like Al lasso it comes
out like with the intestine thing carved
into them it's disgusting I have the
opposite experience when I'm in the
hotel rooms I find myself being Freer I
[__] more it's Road ass too cuz I'll
make bad decisions with my food that's
when I eat the nachos and the stuff and
then I really [__] oh no no I'm good on
the road I think the apples from the
lobby and [__] I'm a [__] Savage got
to eat those apples those apples are
pulling right through you let me read
from my sponsors real quick these [__]
stories are very interesting we guess
you get together more often and just do
a [__] complete anatomy of you know I
love talking about this stuff I don't
know why I I just like and I've had
three or four women eat my [__]
that's not where I picked up my [__]
ankles and I've heard them lap that
[__] no there was this one chick
I used to give a Coke Rock to and I
would grab her by the front of the hair
and go go under and I just put her under
and she would lick it and she would lick
my ball sack and I would [__] hit him
in the top of my head with a dick and
she would sniff my helmet lick oh my God
these women were animals and it was
disgusting the first time she ate my ass
she actually told me to turn around and
I was like
not a million [__] years tell me
what's on your mind she like I like
eating guys's [__] oh my let me go
wash it and I wash my ass I I took I
washed everything after the shower you
just don't go in the bathroom wash your
ass don't come out and she I couldn't
believe it that's the first time
somebody did it to me well you washed it
I didn't know that you were washing
beforehand so that's fine that's fine I
didn't know if you would go like all day
and then at the end of the day like
that's [__] cool I won't even stab my
wife if I'm not clean completely I got
to take a shower I'm the same way and I
got to watch her take a shower you got
to watch sometimes I'll tell her don't
wash your monkey tonight I want that
original oh my I want that original live
Joey I don't want the crispy I want the
originals you like original flavors yeah
like one day of flavoring or do you like
how much flavor at night like let's say
you wash your [__] at 10 at night you
go to bed okay it's perfect at about
6:30 if you got a nice woman her pH
balance is good that [__] is perfect at
[__] 6:30 you just take that thum off
open it up and it's ready for you it's
got a little Mist on it a little Duke no
problem you sniff that [__] out
unbelievable I've known you for three
years the fact that you said and no pH
balance like I've never I never what the
[__] do you think you're dealing with
you think you're dealing with some
[__] kid at the deli with a hat with
a propeller on top you mad [__]
flavor here dog but you didn't wash your
ass every time she every [__] time
that's disg gent you should be washing
your ass three times a day just in case
you bu into some who wants to eat your
what if you walk out right now there
aick that's hot in are you busy right
now fors I will swallow you [__] I will
take every pubic hair out of your
[__] and suck each por out that's how
much I roll what would you do no I'm not
no you're going to you're going to go
[__] you're going to be embarrassed
you're a decent Jewish kid you're not
going to say suck my ass I haven't
showered since the [__] did you
shower after the gym today yes okay cuz
you got show got it cuz that [__] ass
mixes with the sweat it's a different
dimension I can't I can't even imagine
what your butthole is like listen to me
I wash myself before I go to the gym
okay that's how decent I am I take a
shower before I go toiu Jitsu I don't
ever want uh I don't ever want to insult
somebody with my body order your breath
your [__] ears there nothing you
could do it you know what I'm saying I
want the same respect towards me you
know you you brush your teeth you use
the Listerine you do the best you can
you're still going to have nicotine or
whatever the [__] you smoke reefer or
some ass on your breath yeah but you
know you got to respect your body and
respect other [__] people I know I
can't have you coming into my airspace
smelling like a [__] goat just
[__] offensive you're offending
everybody man Tommy and I were in TGI
Fridays in Hartford Connecticut this
week and the waitress had the worst Bo
of anybody I'd ever smelled she would
walk away and then it was like a 3se
second countdown and then it would just
hit us and I was eating some broccoli
cheddar soup and I was like I couldn't
even finish it it was disgusting my the
theory I think it was that the uniform
was old you know maybe she didn't watch
TG that broccoli cheese soup might have
been old don't blame on the waitress I'm
a fat dude and I know at times you when
I was doing blow I had a little Wang to
me I didn't notice it till the end you
got little pockets in your fat that's
where some heavy Dy skin skin skinny
young girl oh yeah you know pretty but
you know these [__] Gentiles they're
animals they want to save on soap and
[__] got to wash your [__] got to wash
you're a woman you got to wash you got
to wash your [__] was that and I listen
I like a [__] when a girl runs like I
like a little sweaty monkey like there
used to be a girl in the Wes here that
would work out with no undies on because
you would see the clip [__] get wet
like you would see the stripe of a [__]
from the inside she would sweat from the
inside and her armpits she was beautiful
and she had long hair under her armpits
she didn't shave her armpits that's
disgusting I didn't know if she wear
Theodor or not but I saw the [__]
sweating and that turned me on that
turned me on I sat there like [__]
drooling like I like to taste that with
some hair like it's got to have hair are
you classic flavors like that like I
want have a little hair the hair gives
it the the Greek salad effect gives it
that [__] uh you wish it something
smell like an onion it smells like that
onion I like that little light onion
Tang just a little light onion once it
gets too oniony right above the CP with
a mat where it looks like a [__]
Pug's Ed you know right there where
sometimes looks like a what's that dog
that's got a wrinkle forehead a pug she
she's got a good
it it squishes up like it's been F this
is like listening to seventh grade boys
this is the best this is just like
Junior High School H I like nuts when
they're clean I love when Tommy has
freshh nuts nuts are the best sure fresh
J you know what family here yeah go
ahead I did something yesterday
morning I got up took a shower I ate
breakfast and I did something oh I did I
I walk with the baby and when I got back
it was h
so before acupuncture I said let me take
a [__] shower that's the least I
could do for Dr Dy that's my Jew girl I
took a shower I put the coconut scrub so
you smell like something you you got to
take off your shirt I like that I go I
took the shirt off when I got it it was
2:00 last night was 11:30 qu to 12 I was
drinking coffee I was right I go you
know what I took a shower at 1 I'm going
to take a I took a shower at 1 it's
11:30 qu 12 I'm not going to hit the bed
dirty and I took my clothes off took my
t-shirt off and I walked to the shower
naked with my little flipflop sound and
[__] you know and when I got to the
shower I had an itch in my nut sack and
I pick my leg up and what I felt wasn't
sweat it's that that uh it's like spam
the spray [__] mixed with like it was
thick and I remember like I grabbed some
of it and I even smell and it was
tremendous I mean for me it was it had
that man it smell like bacon when it's
when it's bore you ever get bacon but
it's really bore that's what and I was
like [__] 10 hours without taking a
shower and not exercise yeah and this is
what came out of my nut sack my [__]
was clean that was shiny Sparkle I
hadn't taken a [__] my [__] was MIA
there was nothing there but just this
graice right here sure it was like I
could feel the humidity like a sack of
oh God I could have put it on a pan and
they could cooked an egg on it nobody
would have know God you would have ate a
ball sack [__] eating eggs at your
house I tell you I don't get sked out
easily that the truth no no no no but I
don't understand what if I would to Tak
a shower from 8 in the morning I'm most
these [__] baboes walk around yeah
cuz most of these [__] Gentiles leave
their house at 7 and they'll go home not
take a shower go to jiujitsu with that
rotten ass and then go home and go to a
bar and talk to women and expect why
they don't get laid I can't get it well
maybe because you [__] smell like a
[__] animal yeah did your wife ever
see these smells or experience the
smells of your balls you were just
talking about if my balls smell I don't
want my wife around them I I appreciate
that I love my wife good for you and I
like when she has like I don't want to
say a dirty [__] but I like when it's
got some wine little musk little musk
nothing wrong how do you like that
monkey L I just got in like like when I
was younger it had to be totally shaven
but recently I don't mind it as much you
like a lot of hair not a lot like it's
just a little bit like a pat do you ever
smell the patch it doesn't have to be
like it can be be all over but like it's
not too like pushy what do you mean all
over like she got leprosy or somebody
pulled no no like it could be like not
just a patch be in a it's that of be a
in a
circle patch up here no no no but like
I'm saying there's a patch and then
there's when they just like they like
what I do what I just trim it so you
like you like the patch I like
everything now doesn't matter do you
sniff the patch ever just put your nose
in it no you'll ask me I've never
sniffed it I mean I smell it but it's
how deep do you smell it I mean how deep
is your love I Deep Is Your Love Is Your
Love Your s smell it that or you just
smell the aroma and lick it and don't
smell it when you're licking it you got
to smell it yeah you smell it but I
don't I don't go in there just for the
purpose of smelling it like it sounds
like you get in there like you're like a
wine connoisseur and like take a deep
bre you need a steak yeah don't you
smell don't doesn't that Allure your T
taste bud first I must have been doing
it wrong that's the whole thing when you
get into that [__] monkey about right
before you lick you hesitate your neck
hesitates and you don't go like a
[__] [__] embarrass it's like a
soft it goes in your mouth and your nose
ridiculous it does it goes in your nose
and your mouth you just do and you don't
even do that that's too loud and you'll
feel it and right in your nose your
baseball player smelling the dirt or
like like that's what like that and you
know and then you get in there and you
lick in it and you smell in different
situations
belly button I like all that [__] are so
[__] bizarre I love it what the [__]
this what you don't talk about this if
you want to if you want to be [__]
good you got to be bad you're not going
to eat a girl's [__] stay at M
missionary she's not going to call you
again you got to get in there pick that
leg up and eat that [__] ass and tell
her to flip over and pull her by the wig
W and let me get another soda Leaf you
don't mind my brother water whatever you
got over there we got let me give a
shout so you have to do your your read
sorry I I I der's here you know my
[__] read I derailed it I it's
Wednesday night why [__] around if I
tell you once I got to tell you again on
it for all
your supplements needs but what I want
to say is they're more in a [__]
supplement they're a way of life they're
a lifestyle they're tremend they get the
most out of you don't [__] look at me
I'm a [__] Savage I'm a fat [__] but
H has done a lot of good for me the
alpha brand is tremendous the shroom
Tech is tremendous the [__] strong
bone is in fact I'm going to go home I'm
going to hit my fan my buddy up down
there to send me some more
product I'm running low why [__] around
be the best you can be take a chance
Columbus did all right just [__] on
it right take a chance Columbus right
what what would we be if col I love your
mind where would we be if Columbus said
that like a m playing video games
nowhere we'd be nowhere we'd be getting
[__] in the ass by Indians with
[__] long feathers on it go to on it
page and press Church c h u r c get 10%
off your order and get keep getting 10%
off get put on the list get on to stay
on the program I'm not [__] around
this is optimum optimum optimization
we're talking about I'm a little [__]
up but I know what I'm talking about
here you understand me I'm going to try
it I like this yeah you want the best
out of you go to [__] uh on it on
it.com and look at uh alphabrain if you
don't [__] like it send it back we'll
send you your money back that's how on
it's not here to steal your [__]
money we're not some Fly by Night
vitamin company they ain't [__]
around that down there in Austin making
things happen look at that look at that
page read what they got to offer if I
told you what they got to offer I just
sound [__] stupid it's not my world
go to hit.com read what they got to
offer the things I recommend Alpha Brain
tremendous if you want to run on all
cylinders if you're waking up and people
tell you you're [__] stupid Alpha
Brain won't help you you're [__]
stupid but if you're having a bad day
and you can't think Alpha Brain is for
you if you don't like it you send it
back and you get your [__] gers back
all right one two three one time you can
do do it you didn't have to send the
product back my next [__] thing that
my girl was asking me about there's
nothing better than nature box out there
if you're trying to get healthy and you
want to eat nutritious tax L late night
or at work you have to spend money in
the [__] fending machine you're going
to go down 7-Eleven and deal with
[__] abdar those [__] middle those
7-Elevens are becoming [__] Arab
concentration camps you're buying that
[__] those pizzas and [__] those
[__] Hindus with that [__] Pizza
Stop Hindus don't make [__] Pizza
okay stop it you're insulting who the
[__] I am now you don't see me selling
Curry stop with the [__] pizza and
the [__] chicken wings gotop sucking
stick to what you know marel six pack of
butter and some [__] wine to [__] the
[__] that lives upstairs at the [__]
ass all right I know what the time we
get we're talking about
NatureBox
naturebox.com nutritionalist approve the
calories protein I love nature box you
understand me I [__] love it let me
tell you what they got here cuz I'm not
giving you people [__] Justice and
that's wrong that's [__] wrong all
right let me put there this way all
right am I going to say something you
ready for this you should be snacking
you you to be smack them more all right
you even find snacks are low in sugar
non GMO and they're glutenfree and they
ship for free did you know that sweet
potato five sweet blueberry [__] onor
the white and black granola is
tremendous listen I wouldn't [__] with
you NatureBox do
naturebox.com promo code Joey that's
naturebox.com promo code Joey Stay full
stay [__] strong you want your dick
to work if you're sitting there like a
Momo eating [__] potato chips it's
going to over ruin your liver and that's
it's over for you what I'm trying to say
is go to naturebox.com promo code Joey
and stay strong Stay full and you know
what I'm going to give you 50% off your
first month's order who does that for
you you think I was just going to give
you a promo code and that's it let you
go away 50% off who gives you 50% off
[__] suckers who tell me who nobody you
understand me I do the same with Hulu
Plus they're giving you $77.99 a month
on a [__] commercial what do I give I
give an extra two [__] weeks when was
the last time you met somebody who
sucked your [__] for two weeks then
charge you two weeks later nobody does
that in this economy no more some cold
out there for a pen even though you're
trying to get the money for the rent you
know what I'm saying also for you Vapor
smokers who have vapor pens and you want
to try it and [__] be different you
want to hang out with your buddies and
be a jack
off
nail nailed life.com that my body Peter
and David I love these [__]
with all my heart they got the best
[__] pen out there in the market they
don't [__] around they'll Mel mention us
and you get 20% off your first order
what's the web page
nail.com nilife.com call the 800 number
David and [__] Peter there they'll
answer the [__] you they know [__] you
know they got all the answers they got
all [__] answers C suckers so I don't
know if you live in the area I don't
know what the [__] you're doing this
weekend my main girl here I'm so happy
you came in thank you for we're not
wrapping up yet I'm just trying to get
this [__] she's going to be in Ontario
Improv with her husband listen it's the
best two [__] you ever spend your
life you understand me$ 22 [__]
dollars Friday Saturday and Sunday
what's the number down in Ontario 909
6666666 that's 909 582 2361 that's 99484
5411 all right and what is it 989 484
5411 also so guys if you're in the
Pasadena area come see me August 9th at
the ice house I'm doing the side room
two shows 7:30 and 9:30 come out cu you
know don't [__] around these are the
same people you guys love don't [__]
around all right she's doing two shows
7:30 and 9:30 on a Saturday or Friday
night no that's a Saturday night small
room and the reason I like is cuz you
can really let your nuts hang I'm going
to say some real [__] it's going to get
[__] weird cuz I like it that way so
come and watch some real [__] happen
it's like 180 people and you can have a
for show come on down $22 they got great
food Pasad the whole area got great food
get some [__] tickets get some sushi
take your wife or your girlfriend or
your [__] lover over to the Ice House
laugh with my girl 626 5771 1894 again
626 5771 1894 that's number to the Ice
House call him up right now I ain't
[__] around Joe Rogan's up there
right now call him up leave him a mess
oh that's right my husband's doing his
show tonight doing everybody's up there
b CH and me I got I got bigger locations
I got
going [__] these [__] you know what
I'm saying got to go to what else you
want to tell me Ain it was a pleasure
having you on we've been trying how long
we've been trying to get this dirty
[__] honey a while you've always
mentioned it that you call her and then
you're out of town well and Joey used to
be like I'll call you at 6:00 a.m. and
we'll do that and I'm like it's not
going happen what happened to your 6
a.m. phone call Monday Monday Monday
okay what happened was I was doing all
this working on I wasn't losing no
weight me and my wife were like baffled
there got to be another problem and then
I sent them s my card I have a sleep
atne machine and you have to send it
it's a computer and every month every 90
days you send it in and the guy called
me he goes hey man you're going to
[__] die do you sleep only with the
machine or do you sleep on a couch half
night and I go no I sleep with the
machine why he goes you ain't sleeping
you're averaging 4.8 hours or something
sleep oh [__] go you got to knock it off
so it's good that I do the Wednesday
night one plus I could guest that come
in it's much
easier um what I say to you what was the
other question I don't even know so I do
that one Monday at 6:00 to get people
jumping people have Weird Weekends they
probably ate a bad dose of [__] they a
little kick in the ass on and that's
what I'm here to do give you a little
kick in the ass reinforce you let you
know it's a cruel world out there got to
wash your [__] you got to be prepared
if you want to get your dick sucked you
got to be prepared you can't go out
there unprepared nobody will suck your
dick that's so true so Monday 6: a.m.
and then Wednesdays I like to do 8:00
and I miss Jiu-Jitsu and I miss spots
but I want to give you the best possible
podcast like tonight I had her in here
and I could really tap into on the phone
we [__] around it's topical but they got
to go up to 20 minutes you know the
husband wants to [__] her all the time
in the morning all day every day what's
up with you [__] stuck what are you
doing this weekend this weekend I don't
know uh there's a fight Saturday which
would be good who's fighting oh yeah I'm
sorry Matt Brown um yeah that's I'm just
excited for next Wednesday that's yeah
that's why we got the podcast at the ice
house right oh that's always so much fun
Miss Pat live podcast with [__]
Miss Pat we got women we I'm a woman guy
I I jizz with women I have a great
relationship with a lot of these women
so uh I like for them to come on and we
talk and I talk crazy but they know at
the end of the day I love them and I
respect course you do Joey you're the
sweetest one I love you than you coming
you're beautiful I always big fan of I
think you're sexy funny thank you Jo and
you have a podcast oh your mom's house
guys listen up we're going to have uh
this Friday Gretchen bonuchi is a guest
on that episode and uh she talks about
she's writing a book about Danny bonuchi
and I don't know if you ever watched
breaking bonad DUI in 2005 it's a crazy
[__] reality show uh so yeah listen
to that we were just in Vice magazine
too or online whatever Vice and uh it's
good it's a fun show we talk about
[__] a lot if you like that a lot of
brown talk I told Tom when who did the
live one but I said it on here too like
you're like I think between you and Ari
it's my fav two favorite podcasts a
thank he always uh talks highly great
thank you you're very sweet to say thank
you no it's just a lot of the shows have
gotten to be like interview shows and
it's just cuz I see it's hard it's not
hard but it's different when it's only
Joey and me and most of the guys most of
the time your shows is just you and him
and it's it's like one of the only
podcasts where you really have to have
listened for the whole time yeah good
because like there's so many running
gags and it's just it's a I don't know
I've I list I've started a while ago I
missed the beginning of it but the very
very beginning yeah I don't even know
where those are when we were with death
squad we started with Death Squad yeah I
got you right at the end of that oh well
hey I'm glad you're here it was fun than
for having guys thank you I love you
guys you going to wash your [__] now
yeah I got to go do a set but I love you
[__] suckers stay black have a great
weekend we'll see you Monday at 6:00
a.m. you bad [__] Joey de.net
for [__] tour dates where am I this
weekend Reno and that's it I ain't seen
you [__] to Brea September oh
good 18th and then I'm in New York the
26th and the 27th of September I'm
taking August off for done I'm relaxed
I'm going to Kentucky with my family
I'll be in Paduka doing a show at a
[__] Coffee House Believe It or Not
holy [__] I'll let you [__]
know that's how I roll now that the
show's over remember to go to
naturebox.com what music you going to
put on cuz you already put the other
thing on so you [__] this up well well
you said where's the music and we have
two songs lined
up I don't know um
oh I'll do this one because I'm sure
both of you hate
it I have a feeling I know it's going to
be yeah I don't even know who sings that
piece of [__] song which one you know
what he's going to play I don't know the
boys are back in oh no no no okay that's
the worst
bro bro